f
welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee I am councelor Keith
wellam and I'm chairing the meeting
today may I first of all remind you of
some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to
leave please ensure your your mobile
phones are ons silent or Switched Off
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or
questions please note that messages in
the chat panel can be viewed by people
watching the live
broadcast I would like to remind
everyone present at this meeting that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training
purposes the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully
excluded I will now ask the governance
officer to carry out a roll call of
members of The Joint Committee and
introductions we have a number of other
council members and Witnesses and
Council Offices here
today uh thank you chair good morning um
I will with a scoll call please um when
you hear your name please mark that
you're present uh Council Dawson here
Council grandon present Council gold
good morning
present Council McCraw present Council
McLaren present Council
Osborne
present councilor
Carter present councilor Casten present
councilor epiny
young present councilor Muller present
and Council Wellen present and we have
received apologies from Council
scarf so the cabinet
members um present today are uh Council
Davis and babber Cabinet member for
communities and also baber's
representative for on the uh
wcsp uh councilor Busby uh baber Cabinet
member for assets and investment um and
we also have councilor Mansel who is the
mids suffk District Council
representative on the
wcsp we also have other uh we have
officers Avail U present at the meeting
today as well we have um Tom Barker who
is the assistant director for uh
planning for growth we have Vicky Mosley
who's the corporate manager for
communities Emily Yu uh who is the
assistant director for Law and
governance and mon officer and Kathy
Nixon who is our strategic director
thank you thank you can I move to the
agenda
please apologies for absence and
substitutions
please yes chair uh Council scarf has
forwarded his
apologies thank
you are there any Declarations of
pecuniary and non- peculiar interest by
members please are there any to
declare
yes yes uh sorry it's not coming up can
you hear me councelor wellam yes
councelor McLaren it's me yes thank you
I'm just declaring that I am a member of
the western suffer Community safety
partnership thank you very much thank
you right we now move on to item three
which is the confirmation of the minutes
of the meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee held on the 14th of
December
2020 are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
please I see no hands
raised could I have somebody please
propose that we accept these as a as an
accurate
record happy to that chair cross sign at
the top and scroll down the menu to find
the blue bar I have started the vote for
you
councelor Casten are you okay to
vote all right sorry chair we now have
um everybody has finished voting and
it's 11 votes for thank you very much
the minutes of the meeting are
approved the minutes of the meeting of
the 15th of February have been confirmed
and will be signed at the next
practicable
opportunity thank you um councelor
Dawson your video is on and your sound
is on so we can um I don't know if it
would be wise to mute yourself and put
the video
off
please thank you very
much uh we now move on to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition
scheme are there any please nonone
received chair thank you very
much the next item questions by the
public are there any questions by the
public please non received chair thank
you and questions by counselors are
there any please none received chair
thank you very
much right we now move on to item item
eight os2 of
17 uh review of the activity of the
western suffer Community safety
partnership now I'd like to take this
review in three
sections first we will hear from the
chair of the partnership and then Vicky
Mosley who is the corporate manager for
communities and councelor Davis and
councelor
Manel I'll then take questions on their
presentations and on the committee
report and the supplementary
paper secondly we'll hear from the
witnesses who are representing a number
of organizations within the
partnership and then take questions on
what they have told
us and then thirdly members of The Joint
Committee will debate the
item so I would like to invite councelor
Joanna Spicer chair of the partnership
to make a general introduction please
right good morning everybody good
morning councilors thank you chairman
for your
introduction uh can I just start off by
saying my introduction is partly going
to be me um and with your agreement
partly um CLA Harvey who's the lead
officer for the Western suffk Community
safety partnership um about the
priorities so very briefly um
introducing myself first um I am a
county counselor uh and have been for a
very long time um with a um and my ward
is actually in West suffk the
constitution of the western suffk a
community safety partnership is part
statutory and partly pragmatic and
sensible um looking at councilors first
um uh we have two County councilors
myself and also I thought you'd like to
know that councelor Jacko is the other
County
counselor and then um as you've talked
about we have councilors from bber mids
and Western suffk um on the partnership
um but we are all of us very clear if I
may say that it may say in your report
today that we're a statutory partnership
but I think I speak for my fellow
counselors here when I say that we're
all determined that we're not stuck in
what statutory we're going to be stuck
into what works for the benefit of the
residents of Western
suffk I don't want to go through all our
membership at this point at all um and I
believe you've got a list of who the
statutory partners are in section
4.2 um of your report but I would add
that the strength of our partnership um
I believe is because we are also joined
by representation representatives from
the education sector and if I've
managing the technology correctly uh
Jane reason from the Albany uh people
referral uni is here today so could
answer questions from you uh we're also
supported um uh by the housing sector
and um your own housing officer Lee
Crowell actually represents the
statutory housing sector and a
representative uh we do have others I'm
not going to run all the way through all
our
membership um secondly um
it during the time that I've led the
partnership I think we've all been very
clear that it's not enough just to sit
down as partners and it's not enough to
um have a a lot of data performance data
and it's not enough to have an action
plan what we is really important and we
owe it to our residents and to our
partners and particularly those not
counselors to actually make sure that we
genuinely um hold each other to account
on those plans and support each other on
those plans and share our ambitions um
we're very well supported by officers
and at this stage I'd want to thank your
officers who are here today uh Kathy
Nixon uh Vicky Mosley and frine Jones um
who've worked with County Council
officers and the West suffk Council
officers to support the partnership um
in every way and I imagine as part of
your questioning today and Clare Harve
is just going to outline our four five
main priorities but what I'm really
anxious today day is that the
opportunity is taken by all of you to
hold us to account on things where
councils and councelors and your
officers can really make a difference
around domestic abuse hate crime
modern-day slavery and so on you've got
a couple of challenges I think facing
mids saach and Bap as I speak to you
today um first unfortunately your
policing boundaries don't match the the
CSP boundaries I believe she's hoping to
join you at some point there is a new
Western area commander called Janine
ratton who's just joined um suffk from
from London from the Met um uh I've had
a meeting with her and she will be
meeting CSP Partners when we meet on
Wednesday this week uh but her um domain
does not include parts of Baba South
suffk um and so on which is I recognize
a challenge and the other challenge
which your counselors and officers are
well aware of your councilors on the
partnership is that substantial part of
Baba is actually what a lot of people
perceive as being
ipswitch and therefore it's really
important that as leaders in the
community safety World counselors and
officers that we do work across our
boundaries too um and support I switch
uh ipswitch Community safety Partnership
of course has to work not just with baba
um mids suffk and us but also the East
suffk Community safety partnership goes
right into um towards the IP switch uh
from the East Direction so for the
future one of the challenges in the
community safety world is that we all
work um together with ipswitch on some
of those problems so chairman with your
Indulgence can I just hand to CLA Harvey
to briefly just give you the um head
line priorities that we have and then I
look forward uh to actually I should
also say thank you particularly to Derek
Davis and Sarah Manel um who've been
very regular attenders and supporters of
the CSP um and I think you're going to
hear from them this morning uh I see
Claire's popped up so I'll turn my
camera and microphone off and thank you
all for asking me today thank you very
much councelor
sper uh over to you Claire good morning
everybody I'm I'm CLA Harvey I lead the
community safety function for suffer
County Council but I'm also part of the
West suffer partnership I thought it'd
be helpful just to set the scene in
terms of some of the countywide
priorities that suffer County Council um
lead on but work in partnership with all
the community safety Partnerships across
the county um so in terms of criminal
exploitation um we've moved to that new
umbrella term um since the last time we
came to this committee a year ago um it
was previously term gangs and county
lines and the new term criminal
exploitation gives us more of an
opportunity um to uh broaden our our
approach um to ensure that we support
both young people and adults who are
being criminally exploited um but also
that we understand that on one hand uh
young people and vulnerable adults can
be victims but also perpetrators so I'm
pleased to say that um in September
public sector leaders um injected 1 uh4
million pound into that project and
going forward um we will work closely
with the community safety partnership to
tackle criminal
exploitation um in terms of violence
against women and girls our our largest
focus and priority is domestic abuse
which we know um uh due to coid has
increased
considerably um in some senses our data
is showing that uh suffk hasn't seen the
prevalence of domestic abuse that is
being reported nationally or be it has
increased and we're looking at about a
20 5% increase so over the last 12
months we've been supporting our
domestic abuse refugees um to make sure
that they can safely uh receive those
fleeing violence um and we've also
stepped up a 24/7 domestic abuse
helpline which I'm pleased to say has
been extended until
2023 domestic homicide reviews we do
have live domestic homicide uh reviews
for the Western suffk uh Community
safety partnership which is part of our
stash Duty um I won't go into detail
suffice to say that the partnership um
has a DHR panel that regularly reviews
all the live Partnerships all the live
um uh dhrs and to ensure that we're
progressing all the actions that that we
should do um within the recommendations
of of the report um and lastly in terms
of hate crime and prevent um much of the
community safety Partnerships uh work
towards preventing radicalization uh and
also hate crime is awareness raising um
and Community safety partnership will
bit less in the last 12 months because
of coid has transferred all of its uh
training and awareness raising over to
uh online um which uh feedback and
evaluation tells us is is actually uh
working really well and actually going
forward um even if we do return to the
office it's likely that we retain that
online presence for uh awareness raising
um and lastly modern day slavery doesn't
particularly feature in the paper and I
think it's one to look out for going
forward so the conab have um invested in
a new modern day slavery team which the
partnership will be working closely with
going forward um and although we are
touching bits of modern day slavy
already in our existing work through
criminal exploitation through violence
against women and girls um there is a
need to look uh much closer at modern
day slavery in its entirety um and uh I
look forward to working with West suffer
partnership on on that new agenda so
that's it for me chair thank you thank
you very much Claire um now I'd like to
invite Vicky Mosley corporate manager
for communities to introduce the report
J2 of 17 um and the supplementary paper
to this item
Vicki uh thank you counselor um I think
both counselor Spicer and also uh CLA
have touched and commented on uh the
majority of the contents of the paper so
I won't repeat um that information again
but it was just to say uh and to
reiterate what the county um what the
priorities of the CSP are um which was
county lines violence against women
girls men and boys domestic homicide
reviews hate crime um prevent and as
from uh October last year as cla's
mentioned uh modern slavery was also um
added to that and much of the work
that's uh goes into modern slavery cuts
across some of the other priorities just
mentioned
above um the partnership tracks this
perform performance and the activities
delivered by all the partners uh of the
CSP with the use of a a three-year
action plan and the action plan has
broken down into five key themes and all
the activities uh delivered by the
partnership are allocated to a
particular theme and those themes are
awareness raising communication training
and education uh projects and Community
resilience and sort of really just to
say that despite Co coid and the
restrictions that have been in place the
partnership has continued to deliver
um multiple awareness raising campaigns
Partners have really come together to
support a good number of those campaigns
and awareness raising activities
Frontline professionals have continued
to receive um training on all if not all
uh most of the priorities including
domestic abuse uh safeguarding hate
crime County um county lines and
exploitation um projects have still been
delivered uh they have been projects
such as uh holiday activity and food
projects which looks at supporting young
people and those at risk of
exploitation but I think really we are
hoping that um we can complete and do
far more engagement activities um in the
coming months as coid restrictions ease
and uh some of the countywide Recovery
Group which is called uh suff moving
forward they've been uh established to
support community and sports groups and
Village Halls Etc to to reopen and once
that's all happened and it's done safely
then we will be able to engage with a
lot more um engagement
activities so hopefully you'll have had
the opportunity to read through the
report and um Claire's just outlined
each of those priority areas and the
work that's going on I think what would
probably be best is if uh the the
partners have had the opportunity to
introduce themselves and then I'll be
happy to take um any further questions
chair thank you very much um before we
move on to the other partners I'd like
to invite uh councelor Davis and then
councelor Manel to to provide a general
introduction to their role within the
partnership and their view on the key
achievements in the last
year councelor Davis you are
muted there we go hopefully well not
hopefully you can see me but hopefully
you can hear me we can see and hear you
yes thank you poor you yeah I'll again
um as as been pointed out the CSP has
worked hard in the current climate to
continue to deliver its action plan
which sets out the partnership priority
areas and planned activity the pandemic
has slowed much of the planned
engagement work however the partnership
has supported a number of excellent
campaigns and it has supported the
development of strategies such as the
selfic violence against women women and
girls men's and boys strategy and has
developed delivered and participated in
an extensive program of officer and
counselor training programs such as
criminal
exploitation disrupting exploitation
hate crime training safeguarding
training and domestic abuse training um
although not one of our priority areas
mentioned above um bab and M has
prioritized its Community safety
resources and over the past six months
to the development and delivery of an
ASB antisocial Behavior Improvement plan
which will deliver transformational
changes to the way we manage ASB
including the implementation of E's the
case management system the development
of a revised draft ASB policy and a
suite of uh documents and Co coper Joys
with a number of internal teams to align
processes procedures and templates work
is also being developed to improve the
website and the reporting of ASP and
links to the community trigger process
thank you thank
you councelor
Mansel um thank you thank you chair and
thank you counselors for giving us the
opportunity to to um talk about the work
of the um Western suffer Community
safety partnership uh given the recent
and tragic murder of Sarah everard maybe
the focus of the committee might be
directed um to the priority of violence
against women and girls men and boys
where has been a countywide strategy in
place which includes uh domestic abuse
and sexual violence um Partners across
the county came together to raise
awareness of sexual violence and abuse
signposting to local specialist Support
Services there was Collective uh a
collective social media um campaign as
well which encouraged staff and
colleagues to wear purple in meetings
and to share photos of this on social
media uh individuals wearing purple and
sharing on social media lighting up
buildings or spaces purple and making
the backgrounds on video calls
purple um mids suffk uh also funded two
pcsos for a two-year period um from the
1st of February 2019 until the 31st of
January
2020 uh these pcsos regularly attended
Community engagements in order to reach
out to L and vulnerable communities up
until February last year 137 Community
engagements were attended and these
included some um engagements with
schools uh to deliver assemblies and
talks uh about gangs county lines and
hate crime amongst others uh police car
demonstrations lunchtime patrols uh to
uh try to engage
students parking patrols um and
attending some school events in total 44
different schools in mids suuk have been
visited uh with some of them visited had
multiple visits uh throughout February
of last year pcsos undertook reassurance
visits to Chinese communities throughout
mids suffk and delivered letters to
restaurants takeaways and nail bars in
relation to Corona virus from March 2020
until January 2021 um the pcsos of
course had to reduce Community
engagements due to the pandemic um but
hopefully that now that we're getting
out of that we can have more engagement
so thank you very much thank you very
much um now committee members do you
have any questions of any of those who
have already spoken please if there are
any questions could you use use the
raised hand
function councelor gold
please thank you yes chair I've got a
couple of questions um I might have
missed it in which case I apologize but
seems to me there's no representative
from the youth offending service on the
on the
team um if I miss I apologize if not I
wonder whether um some could let me know
why um and on on Clare Harvey's report
um that suffk appears to not have quite
the number of um domestic abuse cases as
as other parts of the country can we be
certain that this isn't just because of
a lack of
reporting um and my question question it
so that's one can we be certain it's not
just a lack of reporting and also um
what are we doing to reach these hard to
reach victims um particularly in very
rural parts of suffk where it is quite
difficult to get information thank you
chair thank you um is there somebody who
has already spoken who could address
those questions please yeah I think I'll
I'll ask CLA to pick up the second one
it's Joanna Spicer here um just in terms
of the youth offending service they are
actually statutory members
um I I don't know whether she was POS it
was possible that she could come this
morning um but there are plenty of other
members as as well from other statutory
and non-statutory um and and what I was
trying to emphasize is if if if any
organization is in a position to make a
difference to make communi safer we want
them around our table um I'll let CLA
answer in a bit more detail about the
domestic abuse um reporting of
particularly over the last year it's a
year today I think isn't
it thank thank you chair yes um I think
it's always difficult to say with
certainty but certainly we have regular
conversations with our neighboring
counties and they're also reporting
about the same level of increase that
we've seen about 25% so um whilst
National Charities at sometimes are
quoting up to 75 90% increase um I'm
fairly confident that we're not seeing
that here although there is always the
caveat that it's not safe for people to
um exit relationships or make that call
for help so we'll keep a close eye on
that um in terms of hard to reach um
very timely we have um during coid set
up aort of a task and finish group uh
which the CSP are involved in um to look
at how we can engage hidden groups um
and rurality is is one of those hidden
groups especially relevant to suffk so
um there has been some funded allocated
to that group and working through the
types of initiatives and projects that
we can do to reach out to as many hidden
groups as possible um and also the
hidden groups that we don't always know
about so there are you know the hidden
groups that we know about but we
understand that there are there are more
and there is work underway to to look at
that thank you indeed there are the
known hidden groups and the unknown
hidden groups aren't absolutely yes yes
thank you thank you very much uh
councelor
grandon thank you chair
um preco um times suffk did suffer quite
badly with regard to incidents of county
lines I was listening to an article on
the radio where um the spokespeople were
saying that county lines has actually
reduced during the pandemic and um drug
pedlers if that's the correct correct
word
um were using other ways to um to to
sell
drugs but they were expecting county
lines to
reemerge um once um movement starts
happening again in the
country can you tell
me how um the organiz or how suffer is
prepared for this happening again what
they have been doing um during this
hopefully quiet a period here too um to
be prepared and and and um everything
regarding county lines
please chair I'm not sure we're joined
by superintendent ratton yet so I'll
I'll answer if if I may I can't see um
if if you can but I think if there are
any if anyone else has questions that
are specific for people we hear from a
bit later on it may be best to hold on
to those questions on specific topics um
because there'll be plenty of
opportunity later on when we we have
heard from other
Witnesses but Claire if you can answer
that that's fine but if you'd rather
wait until the police officer is here
that's fine too okay I I can I can speak
from a partnership point of view so um
in suffk we have seen a reduction in
county lines um over the last 12 months
I think some of that may be due to
different motor operandi so that um drug
drug dealers are using different methods
to um traffic drugs into rural areas
such as suffk but um I think it's also
because we have uh we've done more than
ever than we have to tackle county lines
in suffk over the last 12 months we are
um uh continually prepared uh for
different tactics um suffer conab have
had some excellent results in terms of
enforcement working closely with the
Metropolitan Police on
opero um and all our partnership work
has continued so um it's difficult to
say whether it's a direct result of of
coid but we certainly have seen a
reduction and I would like to say that's
down to the hard work of all the partner
organizations in suffk tackling criminal
exploitation and I said previously we've
we've had a a large injection of cash to
help us do that um and that's that's
really important in in helping tackling
this really important issue and do you
think that will give you preparedness
for the future when they suggest that it
may reemerge yes absolutely so much of
that investment is around training
awareness but also Outreach working
communities so that the more that people
know what it is what to look for how to
prevent it we think that we're in a good
place to to try and keep it at Bay
because you know as I said they
continually change the way um that they
they apply their trade
thank you very much thank you uh
councelor McLaren
please thank you chair uh my questions
are uh targeted at councelor Davis and
councelor
Mansel um in the projected action plan
that our two districts are going to do
within the overall action plan I'd like
to know what is
proposed uh um about the Stella Maris
review I have got a copy of that report
and uh um come out of a regulation
background and I was wondering how we
were going to make all counselors aware
of this review and what sort of scrutiny
might be attached to that thank you
thank you yeah thank you obviously
that's within the babber area so I'll
start to answer it but if I may I'll
probably defer to uh Vicky Mosley who
has done an incredible amount of work on
this uh the progress that's been made
over the past year is uh is really
impressive working in partnership with
uh the other statutory bodies as as you
know Mary that have been involved in
this so yes um um a large amount of
recommendations have come forward are
being acted upon and in terms of sharing
that information I think we need to make
sure we've got everything um together
fully before we can do that but uh I'm
sure Vicki will be able to give a far
more detailed
answer thank you thank you are you happy
to do that Vicki yep thank you very much
um yeah as councilor Davies has already
said we uh after the the Stell Maris
review we had the um Anthony Douglas
report and we also conducted our own
internal uh report as well what was
quite
um uh what was quite impressive was that
the recommend ations from from both
reports those recommendations that were
actually about um baby District Council
actually reflected one another so
actually what we did is we took those
recommendations and we we kind we
created quite a mammoth action plan as a
result of that so we have a really
extensive action plan categorized into
um red Amber and green actions so those
that are absolutely uh critical actions
that need to happen have already started
and a lot of them are already complete
so I would say that we are more than
half of our way through completing that
action plan um there are other actions
that are already in train and a number
of actions that are yet to start are
what we consider to be low-level actions
um identified as kind of your green
actions but with regards to the work
that's happened so far um there's been
uh we we've had a really close look at
how we're working internally so looking
at our sort of internal teams and uh
making sure that we are working more
closely together
we have looked at all the documentations
that we typically use to manage ASB and
we've kind of not started again but
we've made sure that all of our
documentation is um up toate that they
that all teams uh refer to the same
documentation we use the same templates
the same guidance same processes um um
we have started on a program of training
and development for all our team so
again training uh internally first of
all looking at those processes making
sure that all of our teams fully
appreciate and understand what that
those new processes are um some of them
are in draft so the the ASB policy is
still in draft and that will be uh
finalized sometime during the summer but
nevertheless we're trying to bring
everybody in to be part of that process
so we can take lots and lots of learning
um one of the critical things in terms
of improving our ASB will be uh how we
manage our ASB panels and the way that
we propose to manage those better is by
the introduction of each which is a case
management system now that's already
been operating in various parts of the
county for quite some time um ourselves
and it B Council have been slower to
take up asins but we are fully using it
um now in terms of our high risk cases
so again internally we've trained all
the officers that need to have access to
e we've um uploaded all of our high
high-risk ASB cases and are also now
looking to upload a number of our other
uh kind of medium risk ASB cases uh and
we are managing the ASB in that respect
the next phase will be to train all of
the partners that sit on the ASB panels
um when that's fully done and that's
expected to happen um this month into
into next month then we will start
looking to manage some of our ASB panels
using that that particular case
management system so there's um a lot of
internal work there's a lot of work with
our partners that needs to be done we're
refreshing all of our document ations
we're refreshing our web pages we're
making it easier for people to report
ASB um and so hopefully we'll be making
some significant improvements uh in in
that respect over over some time and
we've already seen um a significant
amount of uh
improvements can I just come back chair
thank you yes please do to Vicki Vicki
my question really I I appreciate all
the hard work that's been
done what my
question is how are you sharing that
with
counselors uh because uh I think many
counselors will actually be
unaware um of the report and I would
like to see some sort of discussion with
with we'll go with babber District
Council uh oh oh I can see Kathy n in
ahead but um
I think we need to be made aware of what
the report contains which is not good uh
and how we are responding to that and I
think that would be really helpful thank
you oh Kathy would you like to respond
to that or
Vicki indeed if I could say that um once
we um have been through the training and
development for offices that um we um
will indeed um shortly be coming to um
talk to members and um it will form um
part of some member development and
training in terms of um things that um
could be done um
differently um also I um wanted to
highlight the importance of the learning
from Stella Maris not only being
internal um to us in bber and mid suffk
but across the county and so um Nicola
Beach the chief executive of the County
Council chairs a senior officer group of
all the key Partners um to look at um
the action plan at a strategic level and
um also um another member of County
Council management staff chairs a multi-
agency operational group across the
county of which Vicki Mosley is a part
um so that there is that operational
learning and that um operational um
development um across the
County thank you thank you both thank
you chair thank you thank you very much
uh councelor
mcro thank
you thank you chair little bit of slow
reaction time on the computer there uh
I'd also liked to follow up on this
question about antisocial Behavior Uh I
know it's not one of the high priorities
of the community safety partnership
but it is more prevalent than some of
the other priorities and the impact at
Community level can be much greater
because it's more frequent and I'm
hearing the E's case the case management
system the developing reports I wonder
though how this can be translated into
um action in the communities where
people can see at the moment uh you make
a report of antisocial behavior and and
it it is very difficult to have any
action taken upon it and I think that is
what people wish to see how can all this
casework um all this management and all
these studies be translated into um I
won't call it boots on the ground but I
will say action within the
communities thank you very
much Vicki are you happy to respond yeah
that's fine um completely uh agree with
that comment um and I I think it's it is
really important that we look to see how
we we do all that Community engagement
um and for me in terms of my role so
there's there's also housing and there's
also environment protection and we all
have significant um roles in terms of
have officers that work with Community
groups and are like I say boots on the
ground and it is our responsibility to
ensure that that people are aware of
their their rights of what ASB looks
like and again as coid restrictions
reduce
we will be looking to do more of those
kind of Engagement pieces with with um
Community groups sports groups uh parish
councils and we will start a program of
Engagement with in that respect
um sorry I forgotten what part of the
question was now but it was so so yes
and in terms of the resources as well um
I'm sort of bolstering uh Community
safety resource within with my team
because we recognize it has been such a
significant um issue for both bab and
Mis and also it's it is looking at those
processes that we've we've developed and
looking at in particular um the the
community trigger so we have uh improved
uh aspects of our website we've made it
much more obvious and clear how to um to
to raise a community trigger uh and
that's a piece of work that we've
started we did have a community trigger
a few weeks back and that's in progress
at the moment so it's it's making things
easier and more accessible for people to
understand how they can report ASB what
ASB looks like and certainly between my
communities team local officers between
housing officers and environment
protection officers who are the kind of
the the key three teams then who respond
to ASB if they're aware they understand
what what processes are they can share
that when they when they are out and
about working with with our communities
that that's um probably one of the
strongest um ways that we can engage
with our with our
communities thank you Vicki may I follow
up with some please do yes it it just
occurs to me that there is one um new
version of antisocial behavior that we
haven't previously seen during the coid
uh 19 lockdowns it has become antisocial
Behavior to gather in large groups um
potentially transmitting the virus and
that that we've actually seen some
recent police actions that have seen
confrontations based on that very point
and our definitions of antisocial
Behavior may have to change uh if Co is
going to be with us for a long time in
some form or other um there may still be
restrictions on on people's movements
and I just think has that been thought
of and
addressed so in terms of the revised uh
ASB Pro uh policy that's now being uh
revised uh I'm not convinced that we
have looked actually at coid especially
so but these are all things that we can
take into uh consideration now this is a
really timely opportunity to look at all
these new things
like I say that that policy won't be um
completed for a few months as yet and
hopefully looking to get that uh
endorsed late summer early early Autumn
thank you very much thank you um
councelor
ekpenyong
please uh thank you Mr chairman um my
question also relates to county lines um
I'm aware of um some successful
interventions that have taken place in
Stow Market um and uh I am still worried
though that once we sort of get back to
a new normal uh those activities will
begin to uh increase again and I just
wondered uh to what extent we are
engaging with um the schools
particularly high schools and and youth
organizations uh from our training and
education perspective and and what we
would be doing to um effect effect L
increase the patrolling of areas in Star
Market I'm I'm very aware of an area
around the old middle school that's
going to be redeveloped that is being
you has been and is being used for um
drug
purposes thank you um perhaps we'll hold
on to the question about um police in
Stow market for a bit until the the um
the superintendent is with us but if you
could if you could answer the other
points please yeah sure um so we've got
a comprehensive work program to work in
and with schools um in coid times
obviously that that reduced because much
of our training went online but we're um
ready and waiting with with new packages
that that tell us the new tactics so
that we can get that message out to
schools we've got the new Outreach Hub
starting um shortly that will engage
with uh pupils parents carers and
teachers um and previous to lockdown we
had uh trained and uh raised awareness
with uh something like 50,000 people in
suffk which included um many of our
schools so um we we're doing very well
in that regard and hope to get back into
it once um once restrictions are lifted
thank you very much are you happy with
that CC yes um just a quick follow on
then for CLA is is is there any work uh
in that regard going on with the mix in
Store
Market
I'd have to look at our list counselor
but i' be very surprised if we we
weren't doing something with uh all
Community groups um it's an open offer
so um the training package is online and
available uh free of charge for everyone
in suffk really whether you're a parent
career practitioner um we'd welcome
people to to come on board and and learn
more thank you very much thank you uh
councelor dwon
uh yes thank you um I'm not quite sure
who this is sort of aimed at it might be
best to answer it but one of the issues
I had with reviewing this um so perhaps
you might be able to sort of assist is
um this is all about sort of make an
assessment with intention of um making
any changes if they're required and um
what I found is that there wasn't
there's a lot about defining what's
actually going on but there's not a lot
on analysis or evaluation or assessments
or appraisals and what I really found
with this um with some of this it was
all a bit wordy and I couldn't really
get to grips as to actually reviewing it
without the detail and I sort of two
parts came up here um for
example uh contesting the strategy to
counter terrorism is to prevent aims to
raise awareness in our
communities now has this been successful
or has it not been you know it's sort of
talking about what they're doing but
there's we can't really review it
because we don't really know there's no
information here of any Clarity and
again I was looking at the um the the
issue with um urban street gangs because
it says it's not a current
issue um yet we're going to continue to
focus on on this and it goes on to say
talking about disrupting those that
traditionally
existed so I just feel lot of it sort of
contradicting and I wonder whether we've
got whether we can drill down to obtain
more
detail um from some of the members or I
don't know perhaps Council Davis I'm not
quite sure how we can review this
without having we might need to come
back to it in the debate on how we
evaluate assess the
success and progress of all these areas
that they're actually dealing
with um councelor Davis your hand was up
it was next um uh I don't know whether
you wanted to respond to that or whether
CLA is going to respond to that um yeah
thank you my hand was it was a couple of
questions ago really um for for alist if
I start with that then I'll come to
councelor Dawson's um although as you
say CLA probably in a better position
because I don't want to overreach
um what I want to say going back to the
ASB um the first thing I would say
counselor MCC is babber and indeed the
csb take ASB is very seriously um which
is the reason as Vicki said we've added
extra resources to that and we've got a
a dedicated officer now who is very very
experienced in that field another thing
is and I and share the frustration about
um actually being seen to be doing
something but in another um um
partnership uh meeting that I went to it
was explained and and I can't give too
much away on this um but the police do
are very aware of certain situations ASB
but they actually use the ASB sometimes
um to help build intelligence let's just
say for for something else and so while
they may not look to be or a perception
that not much as going on actually there
is an awful lot going on in the
background and and again without going
into specifics for for Council Dawn you
mentioned about the street gangs for
example and again our uh the our
partners in the police do an awful lot
of work on this and while it's not in
babber over the weekend they um they put
in special measures within IPS um which
gave them extra powers to deal with two
street gangs that were having um uh some
violent skirmishes so a lot is going on
and and and while I appreciate it does
look quite wordy and there is a lot of
talk there is also a lot of action going
on behind the scenes um but I'm more
than happy for CLA or indeed Jana to uh
to say
more so can we go to CLA first and then
we'll go to uh councelor Spicer please
thank you chair um not contained with
within the report but um the CSP does
have an action plan that has uh
measurements um key milestones and
that's how we monitor our activity and
obviously for the stasher duties we have
to um submit returns to the home office
in terms of how we're progressing and
how numbers are progressing in suffk so
um it is available but it it hasn't been
included in the
report Jo I don't if there's anything
that you wanted to come in on if I may
come back on that
yes please do yes just councelor Spicer
Sor I want to say something well I think
we're we're having a conversation but
it's a really really important one if I
may say um just to pick up on councelor
Dawson's points here um the CSP meets
actually on Wednesday this week um and
progress on the action plan um is on a
complicated spreadsheet believe you me
you must trust me that the partners hold
each other to account both at that level
and indeed the officer groups because I
do sit in from time to time when the
officers meet and if one partner be at
one of the local authorities or the NHS
or the education housing is not going
ahead with proceeding at speed with the
actions that we've got that are
reasonably polite but nevertheless very
clear questions are asked um and I'm
sure that uh Vicki will be happy to
follow up direct with you um over some
of that progress chairman I wanted to
talk about ASB so I come back to that
later sorry could I come back before we
move on um yeah I quite understand that
they're doing all these things I mean I
spent 20 years doing terrorism so I
really understand the subject um for
your information but what is not here
and we're being asked to review this how
can we review it without sort of some
summary uh it's impossible to review
this uh and it goes throughout the paper
without a sort of summary of evaluating
some of the results or analysis that
information simply isn't in the paper so
I I fail to understand how the members
of this committee are going to be able
to to really do that without that
information it's not you know we can't
properly scrutin I'm sure you understand
that um well if I if I may just add a
bit we're here to review rather than
scrutinize
key performance indicators and so on um
yeah but to
review wouldn't you agree defining
review is about if if we need to
instigate change and we don't know if we
need change because we don't know what
the benchmarks are um well I think we'll
leave that if if we may councelor dorson
to to the debate um as as to whether in
future we need more information um coun
could I intervene from something that
might help inform councelor Dawson
please please Council comes out of the
um the chair's meetings in preparation
for this very meeting it became clear in
preparation for the meeting that due to
the situation of coid 19 in the course
of the last year and amount a certain
amount of changes to methodology that we
were going to have to receive a somewhat
truncated report this year um and I
appreciate that that isn't ideal but it
was either have this or not have
everything so taking taking the point
just being made by councelor Dawson I I
think we just is worth pointing out that
this is not the full review that we
would like to have carried out but it is
as good as we can manage under these
circumstances and and again that's just
for information thank you councel mcro
councelor spy sir yeah I think I'll try
and just first thing is to say that I
see that superintendent ratton has just
joined the meeting um from uh suffk
police so you might want to ask her
decide what do you want to ask her um I
was actually uh just to pick up please
to assure um anybody concerned um within
the odd parameter of confidentiality
there is a lot more information
available and in fact I saw with your
papers today that the um you have
progress reports made to Cabinet um on
the objectives as as well but I'd be
very happy outside this meeting to try
and pick up where the strengths and the
weakness is on progress um particularly
by babber and mids suffk um on that um
as um superintendent ratton here I just
wanted to pick up I think it was
councilor McGraw started talking about
antisocial behavior um and saying it
wasn't a high priority I think what the
report says it's not a high risk that
doesn't mean to say it's not a priority
and one of the things that's really
important with a community safety
partnership
is that we all realize what we can do as
partners and not expect everything to be
done by the police um and District
councils um in particular because you're
a licensing Authority you do CCTV you
are the planning Authority you do
lighting um and count County Council
we've got our links into um obviously
through children services and education
and actually if we work to our action
plans we can make a bit of difference
and and I will never have it said that
it's it's not a PRI a priority uh
because it certainly is and indeed just
to reassure you your counselors on the
western suffix CP regularly ra raise um
antisocial Behavior as issues and
particularly even in villages and and
not just in your bigger towns so thank
you chairman for letting me come in with
that I'll turn my camera off thank you
um Kathy did you want to add something
yes I just wanted to um reiterate that
absolutely in babber and mids antisocial
behavior um is a high priority for us
and particularly um those um medium and
higher risk cases of antisocial behavior
and indeed I mean you've heard this
morning um the range of things that
we've been doing over the last six
months um to improve our response to
antisocial behavior and um I'd want to
say that that has included us reviewing
every single medium and high-risk case
to ensure that our action PL so actually
the um the work we're doing on the
ground um are um you know have all the
right things in them and also that we
are working across the board with
partners because obviously in resolving
um complex cases of antisocial Behavior
the strength is in that partnership work
as well as what we can do um internally
but just was was was Keen that um there
wasn't um any mixed message about
antisocial Behavior not being important
to us here in B and mid suffk thank you
thank you very much now we we are at the
end of the sort of General uh
introduction and and questions um and uh
for the the benefit of superintendent
Janine ratton that is as far as we've
got we haven't yet um received any uh
information specifically from the other
Witnesses um are you happy to to give us
your thoughts or would you rather hear
from one or two others first I
understand you're new to the position
and you've only just arrived at the
meeting I wondered if it's fair to throw
you in at the deep end um if you would
if you would rather wait until one or
two others have have um spoken that's
fine or if you'd like to go ahead that's
fine
too well first I'll say apologies for
joining you late I was on a stakeholder
panel this morning which was
unfortunately un available so apologies
for my uh late joining but thank you for
inviting me um I don't know if it's
useful for people to know I my fifth
week with suffer constabulary I've um
transier from after 17 years in the Met
police um so I am very suffk if you'd
like me to I believe the conversation
you've just been having about ASB if
you'd like me to give you a bit of an
update of where we are on SV I'm be more
than happy to do so um I've been on
quite a few meetings in the last few
weeks and um I I completely Echo what
Joanna and Kathy have just said that it
is certainly you know people may feel
it's not a priority that is not the case
um like most councils the police are at
the moment about to do a very big review
on how we deal with it um things do need
to change it's unfair of me to comment
too much on how it's been done before
but we do need to make some internal
changes and we will be working with
parts on that um I am now the ASB lead
for the force across the whole of the
force um for neighborhood policing so I
won't just be focusing on the west I'll
be working with partners and
coordinating the um forces's response on
that so um I I can give you my personal
assurances it is been considered
priority we are doing lots of work in it
and we very much look forward to working
with partners and making that putting
that in AIT better position thank you
very much um CLA did you have anything
else you wanted to say or did Janine do
you have anything else you would like to
say of a more General nature first I I
don't at the moment but obviously I'm
happy to comment if there any questions
or that's lovely thank
you CLA do you have anything you would
like to add no thank you chair I think
i' cover my update thank
you right do we have Tabitha Griffin
with us from the
ccg sorry chair um I have noticed that
um a couple of the panel members have
not actually managed to be able to join
us this morning so I contacted them and
unfortunately T Griffin um and SAR Nim
has both forwarded their apologies this
morning they are very sorry they can't
they can't join um so I think what that
leaves us with Jam reason for Albany
pupil referral unit that would be
brilliant Jane Jane if you're there
somewhere I can't see you on my screen
but if you are would you like to give us
your thoughts please oh good morning
okay I mean from from a school point of
view the work that the West safety
partnership did um on county lines and
and working with parents in particular
was very well um attended and also very
well accepted and I think it's had a a
really significant impact for families
in terms of understanding those
challenges I can also Echo that actually
from my point of view as a as an
alternative provision our students we've
seen a lot less evidence of um drug use
and county lines and drug trafficking
and Drug selling than we've have in
previous years so that has significantly
reduced which in the cohort of students
that I have that's quite a significant
indicator that perhaps the situation has
has
reduced thank
you so are there any other any Witnesses
who would like to add to anything that
they've already said if not I will move
on to any questions from
counselors so are there any further
questions from counselors then
please
councelor Casten oh there's several
coming up now councelor Casten you are
first thank you very much yes so um we
just heard about the um indicators that
county lines are
reducing um what indicators do we have
and I'm not sure exactly who I'm putting
this to um but um what indicators do we
have of um the amount of drug use going
on do we do we have a way of monitoring
um I don't know emergency service some
calls for related to drug use and um has
that what what have those figures done I
see um CLA Harvey's um come up so thank
you thank you chair um the County
Council commission substance misuse
services so that's always a good
indicator of um how many uh people with
with drug or alcohol issues are access
in support um we haven't seen a
significant uptick in coid um so again
that might be because uh services are
not being delivered face to face but
that is one piece of data that we use to
try and understand um the demand and
supply and I'm sure that um
superintendent ratton can can speak to
any data sets that the conab use in
terms of um that
demand thank you
so I can give some very small amount of
data around the drug ju it it has sort
of gone
down
um slightly the thing I'd say about drug
use data is it's a really um it's not a
very liab data set to look at because
crimes go on for drugs normally when
they're found so it's normally because
there's been a positive outcome of
stopping them happening so it's not
always a very good measure of how much
drug use there is going on because it's
only really recorded when it's you know
found when I'd say we look at um county
lines activities in the recent months
around county lines you know has gone
down we have less active county lines
and that is based on Intel um that's
provided to us that does come with the
caveat there that we do not know yet the
impact that coid has had on county lines
um therefore we are watching with great
interest what will happen as we come out
of lockdown and down the uh road map to
return into you know almost life as
normal but at the moment the sort of
rough figures are showing that there has
been a decrease in drug
offenses thank you thank you very much
that's very
encouraging uh councelor
mcra my apologies chair can you we can
see and hear you well your your now
muted councelor MC Ah that's better
thank you my apologies there um actually
that arises out of some points uh just
made by Janine there um regarding coid
effects I've heard anecdotal evidence um
during the last year uh and I wonder if
anybody on the panel could comment uh
the first one is that there is some
anecdotal evidence that younger children
are becoming involved in what we must
now called criminal
exploitation um simply because their
movements have been uh less obviously
trackable I wondered if anybody could
comment upon that I don't want to be
alarmist about this it's just a concern
and it's only anecdotal and the second
um coid effect that I've been hearing
about is the fact that with people being
confined as it were to a very narrow
circle of people and not able to go out
there have been frustrations vented even
to the point where uh young adults and
children have actually been acting
aggressively towards parents and even
grandparents and again I wonder if if
there is any um anything to this
anecdotal evidence and if anybody could
comment on
those thank
you um can anybody comment um Claire
chair um just on the parent care of
violence um anecdotally we have um been
made aware that that is increasing um I
haven't got any data to support that at
the current time but it is something
that the vog Steering group is looking
into um and in terms of younger people
becoming involved in county lines um
again Janine may be able to to come in
but I'm not aware that we're seeing more
of it it has always been a unique
feature of county lines where young
people are used to traffic drugs so um
it's not something that I can back up
with any data thank you CLA Janine can
you add to that please yeah thank you um
the only thing I'd say is again I don't
have any data to support this but
actually the reports we've had is in a
way we've been able to track um use more
easily for example we've been doing a
lot of work with British transport
police on the trains because there is no
reason for them to be on the train so
actually asking the question of what
you're doing where you're going is
actually in some ways become slightly
easier with us and we have been doing
British transport give us links into
other counties just just to see where
the lines are going so um I can't
comment on the age um because I don't
have the dates support that but actually
some the reports I'm getting back from
the officers who concentrate and work on
these areas they're saying actually in
some ways it's been
easier right thank you I'm I'm presuming
then that uh by by basically by being
out at all you rather stick out like a
sore thumb so uh exactly that yeah and
you have perfectly good reasons um of a
non-drug related nature to ask why
they're out thank you exactly thank you
uh councelor eong please
uh thank you Mr chairman I just wanted
to come back to my question about um the
sort of black spots in Stone Market um
where um people congregate for for drug
taking purposes particularly a new one
that's developed around the old middle
school and I'm I'm concerned that once
activity increases um these black spots
will become hives of drug activity and
wonder
increased monitoring of these places in
St
Market thank you uh Janine did you pick
up that question it was a bit muffled at
times is that something you can respond
to please I'm afraid some of it broke
from it but I think the question chair
was what we're going to do about
monitoring these areas what we think are
of concern to us to make sure we tackle
them if they rise is that was that right
counselor that's that's right
superintendent ratton yes
so um obviously the spots are not known
to me yet however Stone Market is
somewhere I've actually spent some time
out in driving around
um again this is anecdotal and I can't
sort of give any data support this but I
have spent some time with the team out
on patrol and they are very aware of
these areas they're very sensible to
them they're very um conscious and
already patrolling them what they've
been doing during lockdown when these
areas haven't perhaps been as active as
normal is doing some of the other
background work to stop them happening
again um so identifying some of the
individuals and doing some work with
them to stop them having to go back into
these spots when time allows but it is
something we will monitor like I said
I'm now the lead for ASB as well so that
that'll sort of fall under my um remit
so I have to make sure I don't fail on
that one so it'll be some definitely one
I watch counselor thank you very much
thank you superintendent thank you I
have only one more request to speak and
is from councelor
Osborne please councelor Osborne thank
thank you Mr chairman um first of all
I'd just like to um mention the fact of
councilor mccraw's comments and
basically I feel that the word that he
was looking for was hands on but
anyway
right so I you know I've got great
concerns I get a lot of emails about
Andy social Weare behavior and there's
no doubt about it that is the biggest
thing particularly uh in our residential
areas here in subury about Andy social
behavior it becomes a real problem it's
really and I apologize if if this has
already been spoken about but um it's a
question really for councelor Davis who
I know works extremely hard on all all
of these uh Community uh sections but
how is the work being done um and and
fed back to all counselors because here
we've got situations where counselors
I'm afraid don't or are not aware of of
of the problems with antisocial behavior
and it becomes a situation where we have
to then go back to officers at babber to
um to to report it um and I'd also just
like to comment on on the question about
um uh Paul councelor eping On's uh
comments about schools and and and
unfortunately drugs um we've got that
same thing in in subury particularly
with the upper upper upper
um upper school that we have here which
they mix outside after after they break
up uh well they did and uh uh of a day
and and they were passing drugs on
freely and and what's it there which was
very disappointing for a lot of people
so that was again another another
questions that have been asked of me and
and also so uh if if councelor Davis
could speak on that one
please yeah Davis thank you yeah thank
you chair thank you councilor Osborne
yeah as um as both you and um councilman
Mur have alluded to ASB can be quite a
complex issue it's not just a case of
you know some some Lads putting a window
through or anything like that the short
simple answer is obviously the local
police will deal with it if it's a
little bit more complex obviously uh bab
officers will go out and try and deal
with it as much as possible they will
communicate with local Ward members or
they should as much as possible um but
some of the The Wider scale issues um
need more time and if you like more
effort um put into it so it's not always
simple just to give a very quick um
answer because it could be ongoing it
could be longer lasting um and I know as
we've said earlier babber especially um
and mids suffer
are putting more resources into this um
we we have Peter Watson who is now uh uh
a new ASP officer on this which Vicki um
he's relative new to the post so
obviously he'll work very closely with
Vicki and then hopefully we can um come
back to you with more information as we
get it and more reports are are
finalized um Vicki maybe a to give you a
bit more on the actual Hands-On if you
like um detail but that what I can tell
you at the moment on The Wider CSP then
of course you know as has already been
pointed out by Claire and and G you it
is a lot of data which we um do um do
have to compile and then deal with so on
The Wider scale it's uh again it's there
we're doing all the work um but you're
probably making the point we need to
communicate it better with various Ward
members
Vicki yeah and we can absolutely do that
and I would expect as you've pointed out
counselor that for um you know my team
housing teams um Environmental
Protection teams to be doing that with
their cabinet members but also Ward
counselors um and I can ensure go back
to those teams to make sure that is
happening if it's not um but also we
will now that we have uh improved
processes and procedures in place cating
the information sort of um sort of
generically we will be able to pull
those together and obviously provide
more regular updates to to counselors if
that's um if that's what's felt
appropriate and that you all felt that
you would like that so that's not um
impossible we' obviously have to
anonymize a lot of the data because it
is quite sensitive in a lot of cases but
if you're happy for that kind of high
level generic data of number of asbs
type of asbs then in time we'll be able
to give that to you on a regular basis
yeah I appreciate that thank you Mr CH I
would just come back and say um I
appreciate uh your responses and
particularly councelor Davis's um but
what I would say is
there are a lot of more elderly
residents that don't believe that
actually any antisocial behavior
problems are being resolved so um I'd
like obviously like to see uh um some
responses on on how things have
developed in in terms of stopping some
of this antisocial Behavior but thank
you both very much thank you thank you
Mr chair thank you um councelor EO you
still have a hand raised um
is
that um right um sorry chair that's an
old hand I'll get it
down are there any further are there any
further questions if there are not we've
been going for nearly an hour and a half
I would I was going to suggest that we
have a short break before we get onto
the debate um uh Kathy you've got
something you'd like to say before we
break indeed um chair very briefly I'm
very conscious this morning there has
been a significant focus on antisocial
Behavior which I welcome um and I did
wonder um and obviously something for
members to consider yourselves if this
might be a topic for um future scrutiny
in more detail by um this committee um
some months hence um when um we are um
yet further down the road in terms of
our antisocial Behavior action plan yes
comment thank thank you I think that is
something which we could we could
definitely discuss in debate um
councelor m is it a question please uh
no an observation to that very point
just made by Kathy that in fact there is
one area that we haven't focused on it's
very much in the public mind at the
moment and I hope that it will come up
in debate which is violence against
women and
girls I think that is something that is
always a priority for everybody and it
requires us to spend some time on it in
debate I hope members will do so I'm
sure I'm sure members will thank you for
that councilor mcra it's 10:54 according
to my laptop so could we just have six
minutes and be back by
11:00 give you a chance to fresh air or
get a cup of coffee or whatever so we
see you all back at 11:00 please thank
you
uh thank you so um we've we've heard
from Witnesses and we've questioned
Witnesses and we're now on to the
debate so would somebody like to start
the debate U we heard from uh councelor
McCraw that we ought to concentrate not
solely on on antisocial Behavior but on
other matters as
well so do I have somebody who would
like to to speak on whatever issue you
wish to speak on from the report and
from what we've heard this
morning councelor
mcro well I feel since I raised it um
and it may result in some questions for
uh for um officers and uh the members of
the panel but um I wanted to focus on
the contents of pages 24 and 20 sorry 26
and 27 in the report we heard earlier
that um greater resource has been put
towards uh the violence and domestic
abuse issues um covered by the community
safety
partnership because there's been a 25 or
22% increase whatever the percentage is
it's increase from what was already a
bad
position and and I always wonder when
when we're um reviewing this particular
section of the safety Partnerships work
what value we can add um Beyond saying
please keep keep doing what you're doing
um and it's difficult to know where we
can add value um I don't know if any of
the panel wants to comment on this point
particularly it was touched upon and I
think perhaps it could be touched upon
further I think I'd like to hear a
little more from the panel members on on
how they see things going
forward I know this is a question and
probably not something for debate but I
think best do it now well I I I think I
think you're right and and if I could
add to that um my understanding is that
the solve rates are not particularly
good and not not improving in terms of
violence against women and girls boys
and men and and domestic abuse and
whether there is anything that we can be
told about that and anything that we can
do to help issues around um uh improving
Sol solve
rates so I don't know whether the
superintendent um can assist us on that
or any any other of our Witnesses
please I'm afraid I don't don't have
probably enough data to speak with any
confidence on that it is obviously
something that the police are very um
aware of at the moment and conscious
especially with recent events um but I
just don't feel I have enough data to
speak with any Authority on that at the
moment um so without that I understand
that in terms of the data but is there
is there anything that that any of the
panel could could um think of that we
could we could help with
CLA did you want to come in yes please
chair I mean I think um when we came a
year ago we absolutely promoted our
domestic abuse Champions training um
which is not just about attending
training understanding what domestic
abuse looks like and and where to refer
but also to embed champions in all
organizations so that if a a colleague
or a uh you know someone someone in your
um social field discloses to you so that
you know what to say how to react um and
what to do in in that moment and we are
continuing to train more and more
domestic abuse champions in suffk I
think we're up to 358 at the last count
so um that's certainly something that uh
members um and organizations can do but
I think in terms of the community safety
partnership um the number one focus is
to um support the systemwide response to
um make every opportunity um available
so that people can report safely and the
CSP are doing that by getting messages
out um to CSP partners of where to refer
to particularly promoting the new 247
helpl line um for us certainly as a
County Council it's about ensuring that
people have somewhere safe to go so
that's domestic abuse Refuge but also
satellite accommodation um which caters
for um those people who are fing abuse
that aren't necessarily suited to
communal Refuge so um there's lots of
stuff we are doing lots more we could do
but I think very much sits in that um
promotion domestic abuse Champion space
in terms of the partnership thank you I
can recall I'm not sure this last year
or the year before we we had concerns
about the amount of accommodation that
was available ref uh Refuge type AC uh
accommodation uh and spec specifically
for men and and boys if they were
victims of abuse that there didn't
appear to be um a great deal of
accommodation available locally and um
there have been anecdotal evidence of um
uh people having to leave the the county
or whether that's because that's to
their advantage it's safer for them to
do so um I just wondered if there is
sufficient Refuge accommodation
available within
suffk Sher if I could just come in so s
County counc commissions um the refugees
and I think we did discuss this
previously I think the first point about
um refuge for men um it's very unlikely
that if you're a victim of domestic
abuse within suffk that you would seek
Refuge within your county so it's quite
normal that that you would seek
accommodation um elsewhere um I'm sorry
forgive me chair your second Point well
what whether there whether you have
access to sufficient accommodation that
was really the point and so uh in in the
last 12 months we have commissioned an
extra 19 bed spaces uh working with
local Authority Partners um on top of
the Refuge spaces that we already have
um and you may also be aware that the
government announcement a couple of
weeks ago is that um in return for a new
domestic abuse um accommodation Duty
that will sit with the upper tier
authorities we will be getting some
funding and so fully intend um to extend
our offer of accommodation and hopefully
um if we come to the panel again in 12
months time we will see our bed spaces
grow thank you very much um councelor
mcro did you want to come
back I'm uh happy to wait for councelor
grandon to go first councelor gon's T
councelor grandon are you still wishing
to speak your H yes well there was only
that I was going to ask about the
satellite accommodation going through to
the end of March and was asking whether
that's going to be extended I think that
may have been answered with the last um
with with with the last um
questioning is that correct the the yes
yes both both the uh satellite
accommodation and the 247 helpl line
have been extended thank you thank you
lovely thank
you thank you so councilor mcro yeah I
do have a suggestion chair um and I
think it it leads out of this and
towards recommendations in previous
reviews uh we have looked at trying to
provide positive outcomes from this
review and uh one of our previous
recommendations was the preparation of a
confidential information pack and it
must remain confidential since it
contains numbers that will not be
generally
known prepared by the community safety
partnership and provided for the use of
Ward members across both
districts uh the one I have on my
desktop um which I keep there is dated
2018 um I think suggestions have been
made for uh it to be updated I'm not
certain that it has been I can't find a
more recent version and it obviously at
2018 it cannot be up toate so I think we
should be definitely looking towards uh
having that updated as potential
recommendation um and perhaps some new
information added to it particularly as
as the circumstances will have changed
since then
I wonder if that would be with within um
if Vicki could comment upon that whether
that would be possible to have prepared
for
members Vicki are you able to comment on
that please yeah that's fine yeah I'll
take a look at that data set and see
what is available and um work across all
of our partners to see what else can be
can be added to that and then um draft
something for everybody's information
the reason I mentioned this Vicki is
because I think I think again it's this
slight disconnect where members don't
necessarily feel that they have a direct
role and bearing in mind if you have
that information available and somebody
brings a problem in your patch in your
ward to your attention you are not left
having to immediately phone around
various officers to find out who you
should speak to you have somewhere to go
and therefore you can progress it
obviously without giving out
confidential information this is
absolutely absolutely crucial that it
should be clearly understood perhaps
printed on pink paper that is a
confidential document because it's part
of our responsibility as Community
leaders to be able to uh to make those
contacts we're a first responder in that
very not a proper response you know what
I mean we're a first responder at Ward
level and I think that would help
involved members directly in the work of
the safety partnership sure yeah no
problem yes and if it was dated 2018
there may be some members who never
received it so it will be worth sorting
that one out uh councelor McLaren
please thank you chair I think a lot of
us are thinking on the same lines really
um I would I just before councilor mcro
spoke uh I just want to say that I do
agree with Council dwon in
part about the poity of detailed
information um I understand all the
issues around
confidentiality uh but I'm on the health
scrutiny committee which is equally
confidential and I think it would be
helpful to us as members to have had a
bit more detail uh from the partnership
in relation to changes perhaps from last
year to the this year or um taking
cognition of the coid uh pandemic but I
I think it was a bit light I've got to
say the the report itself was a bit
light on the detail thank you chair
thank you councilor McLaren Tom Tom
Barker would you like to come in uh
thank you chair yes um conscious that
the conversation may have moved on
slightly but just um recognizing that
there have been various uh requests for
kind of more detailed information and
data I wondered whether it would be
helpful for members um in terms of the
questions around um uh domestic violence
and satellite refugees and and such like
just to to update since the 1 of April
2020 so over the last year essentially
um as councils we've accepted a duty to
30 households who have fled domestic
violence 16 in babber and 14 in mids B
of those 30 cases um we've got four who
are still in temporary accommodation one
in a uh satellite refuge and 24 of those
households have had positive outcomes
which includes our duty being accepted
to them under homelessness legislation
and they've been rehoused either via
private rented or social housing I just
wanted um for for members to be aware of
that kind of specific information thank
you very much
um if I can come back just as councelor
mcro did about the the the uh amount of
data we we really were in the position
that uh because of Staff being uh
allocated to coid related duties uh away
from their normal duties and for a
number of other a number of other
reasons we had to make a choice of
either bringing a a report um to this
meeting or to wait until there was
um sufficient data or more data and that
would clearly have taken us uh Beyond um
the County elections and could well have
taken us towards July so um our feeling
was it would be better to bring uh some
information here in March rather than
wait until wait until July when more
might be available um so uh yeah I mean
I I accept that it was was largely my
request that we did come to this meeting
um and officers did point out that
because of that there would be less less
detailed data than than would normally
be the case but my feeling was that
there was sufficient for us to carry out
a review of their activity the activity
carried out by the partnership um H and
well we are where we are so um there may
be some areas where
um members would like more information
in due course um and we can note that uh
the next annual review um that there
needs to be more data um but we are
where we are and I we've reviewed um
what we can uh and I think we've had a
we've had a good uh sounding of what's
what's going on in the county orbe it or
in the western uh Western area or orbe
it not the all of the the data that we
might have had um but uh is there anyone
else who wishes to debate or if that's
not the case can we move on to consider
um
recommendations um and proposals please
had um a request that the um the
confidential information pack is updated
and expanded and any relevant new
information
added there's also been a
suggestion that uh there might be a a
briefing to counselors on uh antisocial
Behavior at an appropriate time um uh a
sharing of procedures processes and
action plans um there was a suggestion
that might be a scrutiny topic but I
wonder whether um members would see that
as a scrutiny topic or whether it would
be better that the information is given
to all members members at an appropriate
time um councelor Dawson I see that your
hand is raised um yes thank you yes I
just wanted to be really clear um
you I mean I I I would really like to
see not sort of some detail on the
analysis I'd quite like this noted going
forward analysis assessment and
appraisal because we we really do need
the detail i i i i i at the moment I'm
still at a loss to understand how we're
going to review this and I don't believe
it should have been rushed forward
without this critical information you
know all we've got is we know I mean I
have no I know what they do um and this
is my first time reviewing uh this
partnership and and it's excellent but I
have really no idea whether they're
doing in simply simple terms a good job
or a bad job you know whether there's no
um audit there's no
examin you know even Minor Detail isn't
there so uh we have to be really clear
going forward what it is we actually
require and we don't want streams and
streams of paper it could probably be
all summarized on a couple of sheets um
but it is very critical that this
information is provided because I I I I
I believe this paper shouldn't have been
brought forward as it is at the
moment thank you
um does anybody else wish to
speak
um I have no other hands at all uh
councelor eong thank
you uh thank you Mr chairman I I'm I was
thinking about the recom the the idea
that uh Kathy Nixon put forward to look
specifically at asb's uh at a future
meeting um but it does occur to me that
there from what I've heard that there
are a number of of these areas for
example the change from gangs and county
lines to criminal explo exploitation and
and and and the addition of modern
slavery for example that actually there
are huge these are all huge topics and
each of them um actually could probably
bear examination in their own right and
I just wondered whether in fact our
approach ought to be to take them in
turn I mean I know they meant some of
them are quite interl um and maybe
that's a consideration as to how we deal
with them but I do feel that um I tend
to uh have sympathy with councelor
Dawson's uh commentary about uh what
we're trying to do here and it does seem
to me that it's really not sufficient
given the the uh you know the importance
of these
subjects thank
you um so that seems to be be a
suggestion that this scrutiny committee
looks at a number of different aspects
possibly spread over the next year um or
alternatively that we wait until we've
got an opportunity to review everything
on a the basis of data summarized as
councilor Dawson has suggested um what
are what are other uh what are other
members views please councelor mcro
I think um there's a difficulty here in
that our responsibility is a statutory
responsibility that we are required to
review the work of the west of Western
suffer Community safety partnership
every year to do it this year this was
the time that was available if we had
left it till July it would not have been
within this year and we would not be
fulfilling our statutory
responsibility second point is that
review means just that we're not there
to duplicate the work of the Western
suffk Community safety partnership both
councils have a counselor representative
on that body and dealing as they are
with a lot of confidential information
and meeting regularly we have to allow
them to get on with their job so our
responsibility here is to satisfy
ourselves that the work of the community
safety partnership continues in a proper
manner and that the issues that we have
raised are are being attended to we're
not really there to pick apart the
detail work um as perhaps might be
suggested by by by members comments I'm
not saying they're wrong I'm just saying
that there is a limit to what our role
here can be and obviously we've done
this every year for the last four years
that I've been on this committee so that
alone gives me a certain amount of
confidence in in the the direction that
we're traveling
in uh I think we should probably go to
go to recommendations at this point
because I don't know that we can take
this any further as it is we have what
we have before us and we will be
fulfilling that statutory
responsibility thank you um I I'll I'll
hear from councelor dwon and councelor
MCC if you'd like to think about a
content of recommendations in the
meantime that would be brilliant thank
you councelor
Dawson yes just to say uh I agree with
councelor MCC we've got the
representative on there um perhaps that
councilor representative should really
have given us a verbal could he give us
a verbal bit of
detail which he hasn't done um perhaps
he could to just Enlighten us all give
us a brief if he if he's seen he
obviously has seen this information um
he's looked obviously knows some the on
some you know he must have an overview
on some of the detail as he's the
representative could he could he could
that come forward
briefly at this point councelor Davis
would sorry are you looking for me to
repeat what I said
earlier no what we're looking for you to
do is for a review this requires some
sort of audit
analysis
investigation and as Council mcro said
you're the representative we don't want
to REO over these things at today's date
so perhaps you as the
representative could just give us all a
sort of synopsis of the
detail because it's not in the
paper um well I don't know what other
counselors think but um I think I think
that the paper presented by Vicki um is
quite comprehensive and it it gives as
much as we can at this stage and it's
the same with the paper from uh Claire
and Joanna it's quite a wide ranging uh
overview of what we've been doing over
the past year yes yes it says what
you're doing but it hasn't got to
conductor ofie it needs um as Paul epong
and others have said it just requires
some detail do you recognize that that's
maybe you
don't uh do you recognize that's not
there I'm not really sure what what more
you I think we're gonna get an answer on
this one don't worry um I I I think I
think what we've been looking for and
have looked at in previous years has
been to get an overview of the activity
and to to discuss the activity and and
to point out uh various asp aspects that
uh we would like to be look looked at in
Greater depth or actions to be taken
such as the confidential information
pack um I don't I don't recall seeing
masses of data or any any detailed data
in previous years because really I think
it's a matter for the um the partnership
to ensure that the various partners are
are are acting as they should within the
partnership um uh an in that aren't we
we're reviewing that that's the whole
point and you're overseeing that as a
representative so you should be able to
tell
us I I think we've gone as far as we can
on this well I think I think I think we
have and and I think Emily Emily did you
want to come in and say something
please yes chair thank you for for
bringing me in and good morning
counselors um chair the report that
you've got in front of you today from
the community safety partnership
is commensurate with the type of
information that's been presented to the
overview and scrutiny committee before
its customer practice to receive this
kind of um update if the committee would
like to see different information in the
future I think it's reasonable for you
to agree that in your scoping of this
item so I think it's wholly unreasonable
today to start asking for performance um
statistics or or metrics when that's not
being requested in the scoping of this
item but it is something that the
committee could think about in the
future if you believe that would enable
you to do a further um scrutiny or add
further value to the scrutiny process um
I just think it's it's unreasonable to
try and put cabinet members and other
Representatives on the spot today with
that information requesting that
information when it hasn't been uh
requested in advance as part of the the
scoping of the item thank you chair yes
thank you very much that that is helpful
and um and we could add if it's members
wish to um to to add some detail around
uh what we might like to see next year
when this annual review comes again um
but I think it's quite right that um
we've not we've not seen we've not asked
for that sort of detail in the past and
particularly during the last 12 months
it would and the extra work that
officers have done it would be
unreasonable to put them on the spot now
um did you want to add something you've
popped up on the screen I forgot to take
myself down only that I do have some
sympathy with councelor Dawson wanting
to see that kind of um progress from one
year to another to understand what maybe
some of the pinch points are where we
need to focus our our attentions that's
certainly something that I will take on
board we'll start building that picture
up and we'll be able to bring back um at
some point so that's fine thank you
thank thank you very much um councelor
Dawson your hand is still up are you are
you reasonably content with that
response yes I am thank you so I've Tak
my hand down thank you very much thank
you councelor
McLaren thank
you sorry thank you chair can I just
um ask the chair and members whether
whether the
the way the
recommendation was
designed uh that it people look at that
because the recommendation was to review
and scrutinize now scrutiny is something
that we do would it be better if the
recommendation was to review rather than
add the scrutiny into it just to make it
more um you know ad meable to everybody
uh councilor mcfar I think you're
absolutely right and and I think the
recommendation would be if it was agreed
would be something along the lines of
that the Joint Committee have reviewed
the activity rather than we we have
reviewed and scrutinized the activity um
uh so the the two recommendations there
could possibly be rewarded to um having
reviewed the activities the partnership
the committee and committee have also
noted the report um so thank you
councelor
McCraw oh
dear my apologies chair we can see you
and hear you now oh that's fine it's not
showing on my screen a little delay I'd
just like to draw members attention to
the agenda
supplement
indeed um you've gone mute now councelor
mcro can you hear me now yes we can I'd
just like to draw members attention
that's a quarterly report provided to
both cabinets um and comes from the
community's team that in itself uh
provides a sort of Fairly constant
update uh but I'd like to just move move
to some form of recommendation beyond
the ones presented um as the chair has
suggested I I'd like to have a further
recommendation that the previously
prepared uh members confidential
information pack be updated expanded
where necessary and distributed to Ward
members for their use and perhaps um
some basic background could be provided
in within the information pack to give
them the context so they may use it
effectively thank you I'm just making a
note of that uh something along the
lines of previous the previously pre
prepared confidential information pack
be updated in additional information
added and
distributed to all members y um I say
with some context provided but I think
that's going to be discussed with Vicki
and and between Vicki and the um the
babber mids Representatives but it that
it should be done and distributed as
soon as it's reasonably
practicable right I'd make that
proposal thank you uh councelor grandon
I so your hand is
up yes thank you um just going forward
um when we were talking about level of
detail that we may require or otherwise
um I don't think we need masses of
detail but perhaps um alongside the
information we've currently been given
um an assessment of the activity
followed by a simple
um s level of success or otherwise a
quantifying near the level of exess
success that activity has had um would
be helpful that's all really in my
view thank
you thank
you um does anyone else wish to
speak or can we try to fine-tune the
wording of the
recommendation to something along the
lines
of the Joint Committee have have re uh
have reviewed the activity of of the
community safety
partnership and noted the content of the
officer's
report um and have the following
observations um that the previously
prepared confidential information pack
be updated additional information
added and distributed to all
members uh something along the lines of
that um the committee would like to
receive at the next annual review um uh
a greater uh assessment of the success
of the activity undertaken by the uh
partnership and did we also want to add
something uh a specific
proposal around um
um a a briefing either in a a written
briefing or a um a a virtual briefing of
members on the procedures processes and
action plans of the um of the of the
district councils in respect of the
antisocial Behavior
area have I got any comments on uh
councilor
mcro I'd support all three of those
recommendations chair
thank you uh councelor
dwson um yes I I would just you know gu
government guidelines do stipulate quite
clearly
um I i' would like to see just slightly
more clarity I'm just worried we're
still a bit woolly on what's going to
come forward next time um it really
needs to we I don't want this in detail
but like if it needs to be about the
audit the inquiry evaluation you know it
needs detail and that can be easily
preed down you know it really can be but
um you know that's what proper
governmental review and scrutiny is
about
um I'm just slly I'm not convinced if we
just sort of say we want more detail you
not we're not going to get what it is we
require to review this properly can I
can I ask for advice chair from the
monitoring
officer yes please do yes uh em you
could like to ask if we actually have
the ability to um to do what uh
councilor Dawson is suggesting given
that so many other bodies are involved
in the community safety partnership
would we be overextending our reach in
governance
terms so the overview and scrutiny
committee has the ability to call upon
on any witnesses that it requires to
enable it to conduct an effective
scrutiny and to ask for any information
uh to inform that scrutiny um I would
suggest chair that given that no
counselor is um proposing any specific
information at today's meeting that
actually you probably need to make a
more General recommendation today and
then task a number of counselors perhaps
councelor dwson would like to be part of
that to then work up what that means in
terms of the specific information that
you would like to request uh for the
next uh annual scrutiny of this topic
I'm happy to do that and Emily should we
do that as a as a formal group or just
informally by the chair's uh contacting
informally would be yes informally is
fine chair thank you so um councelor
dwson what I've written down then
perhaps that this would satisfy you for
now the next annual review to include an
evaluation of the effectiveness of the
activity of the partnership and then we
will we will discuss the detail that
needs to go into that
evaluation uh it's the effectiveness and
it's did you say evaluation evaluation
of the effectiveness yes yeah
okay thank you um councelor
eong
please uh thank you Mr chairman i i c
perhaps uh what I was going to suggest
is covered I mean it seems to me that
the the partnership has a set of
objectives that it it driving to achieve
and and a number of metrics that it uses
to measure that and I think really what
we're looking to be doing is is
effectively scrutinizing and evaluating
those and it doesn't need to go into um
huge amounts of detail as councelor
Dawson has pointed out so hopefully the
uh ad hoc group you're going to put
together will we'll find a way to put
that together for the next time thank
you very
much um so what what I've scribbled down
here
is that
um um we um having reviewed and the
effectiveness sorry having reviewed the
activity of the community safety
partnership we've noted the
report um h
um and previously prepared confidential
information pack to be updated
additional information added and
distributed to all
members um Arrangements be made for a
briefing of members on the procedures
processes and action
plans um of the of the councils in
respect of the um uh antisocial Behavior
and that the next annual review to
include an evaluation of the
effectiveness of the activity of the
partnership there's quite a lot of words
in there um is that the sort of thing
that members have in mind is there too
much there is there enough there is
there any member who would be like to
comment on that or even any member who
would like to propose something along
those
lines
I'm happy to propose it thank you very
much councelor
Dawson and do I have a second to please
councelor
Pon uh yes chair I'm happy to second
that thank you um I don't believe
there's any need for any further debate
on that unless some somebody feels quite
strongly that that is
necessary
um and so Henry I've got it scribbled
down here I don't know how much you've
managed to uh to write
down um I believe I have most of it
chair but um apart from the arrangement
made for member briefings to be sorry
um arrangements to be made for briefing
me members of the councils on
the I guess the the I guess just the
action plans will will be necessary in
um uh in respect
of um antisocial
Behavior okay councelor Carter you've
got your hand
up PA just chair that was raised earlier
and it's only just popped up now so it
seems to be doing its own thing all
right thank you very
much so members are you content that we
vote on
on those
recommendations um just to confirm chair
the information pack update is included
yes it is thank you yes previously
prepared confirmation confidential
information pack be updated additional
information added and distributed to all
members so okay yes chair I have it all
now
would you like to go to the vote chair
yes please or would you like me to read
it all again um does does anybody want
to have it all read again or you content
that we've captured it
all I'm having no hand saying it's got
to be read read again captured it's all
captured Mr thank you very much
councilor Osborne um so can we can we
then all go to the electronic vote
please
and it is to note the report and agree
the recommendations as read by the
governance officer and that not vote
that's now in progress I believe yes
I've started the vote for your members
if you please can go and cast your vote
on the
app
I have still not received votes from um
councelor Casten councelor grandon and
Council
dwon uh mine seems to have gone through
it's it's fine it's coming through now
as I speak thank councilor grandon are
are you still okay oh we have all the
votes now chair sorry about that thank
you and it's 11 votes for thank you very
much thank
you um can I can I thank everyone who's
attended specifically for this this item
the the offices and members who have
attended thank you very much it's been a
very full discussion um uh so yeah we're
very grateful that you were able to to
to attend for
that we now move on to the next item
which is the forthcoming decisions list
does does any member have any comment on
the forthcoming decision list
please thank you the decision list is
just for noting um can we take items 10
and 11 together they are the Baba and
the M mids overview and scrutiny work
plans does anyone have any comments
on the work plans if so would you raise
a hand please use the raise a hand
function if you have any comments to
make no well that's great thank you very
much the babber and midu at work plans
are for
noting uh there is a baba only item
still to follow but before I hand over
to councelor mro will you please note
that the next joint overview and
scrutiny committee meeting will be on
Monday the
20 Monday the 22nd of March it says on
my script um sorry uh the next can you
help help me with the date of the next
meeting please certainly T um let me
just um I do apologize for that error on
my behalf let me just have a look the
next joint over your scrutin committee
will be in uh
June no it will be in sorry it will be
in May I do apologize olze and it will
be on the 24th of May 24th of May thank
you very much I'm sorry for I do
apologize at 9:30 at 9:30 thank you very
much um now I'm I will now invite
Council mcro the chair of Baba overview
scrutiny committee to chair the rest of
the meeting and mids members may leave
the meeting at this point if they wish
thank you very
much thank you very much C C wellam uh
with members permission before we
commence with the next part of the
meeting I propose that we take a short
break perhaps to
1150 that gives members six minutes to
gather their thoughts ready for the
babber specific section of this
meeting all members understand and happy
with
that yes chair understand and happy
chair thank you yes thank you we'll be
be back in 5 minutes
then
good afternoon uh members members of the
public uh and members of mids suffk
District Council who may still be
attending uh this is the bber section of
today's overview and scrutiny committee
meeting and we will be dealing with
specifically babber matters um to that
end I think the best thing to do to
start with would be take a roll call uh
of the babber members and I would ask
the government's officer henriet
Holloway to carry that out
now thank you ch um I'll start your R
call now please respond uh councilor
dwon present councilor grandon present
Council gold present Council mcra
present Council McLaren present and
councelor Osborne present all are
present chair thank you very much
members well um before we carry on then
we'll get straight into uh item 12 on
the agenda today which is BOS 20 stroke
to confirm the minutes from the meeting
held on the 15th of February
2020 that can be found on page 47 of
your uh original agenda are there any
comments on those
minutes okay no raised hand
seen can I have a
proposal for those minutes to be
accepted
I see councilor Osborne
proposing prop second from councelor
dwson councelor dwson thank you very
much councelor dwson uh a governance
officer will now call or conduct the
electronic vote if you'd like to go to
the plus
sign yes M the vote is in progress uh
you might have to scroll down um to uh
get to the vote if you can see it it
should be highlighted in blue
thank you chair uh we have received all
Pap members votes and that is six votes
for Thank you very much henriet item 13
on the agenda is the Callin of the
babber cabinet decision made on the 11th
of March
2021 um before we go any further I'd
like to review the uh papers that we
have in front of us um so that all
members have got all the information as
well as the um original minutes for this
meeting we have uh various supplements
there is the cabinet report that was
presented to members of the cabinet
which has been provided as a printed
copy for members of this committee so
that they can go through that I draw
your attention specifically to the pink
papers in appendix D any um reference in
debate um or discussion or questioning
on the specifics of appendix D would
make it necessary for us to go into
confidential session under part two
regulations and I ask all speakers in
the meeting to uh to uh bear that in
mind if we uh need to come out of
confidential session we have the option
of course to do so I'd prefer as much of
this meeting to be conducted uh in a
transparent manner an open session but
if it's not possible it's not possible
the other papers you have available for
you are uh the uh agenda supplements I'm
just going through them now the largest
of these uh actually contains the
entire um INF infrastructure plan for
babber and
miduk um and in fact that could be
defined defined as probably not crucial
within the cabinet discussions it's been
provided for us simply because it was
provided to the cabinet uh therefore we
must have the same information available
the third supplement is a um I'm sorry
I'm going through so many pages
here second supplement is the protocol
itself for the call-in which is going to
be an item on today's agenda agenda item
14 that will need to be agreed and the
final agenda supplement is a statement
from the monitoring officer on uh the
this matter I propose to insert the
statement from the monitoring officer uh
within the
protocol at the point uh
6.5 just after 6.5 when the cabinet
members and the lead signatory have
completed their summaries of their
respective cases I believe that will be
the appropriate point and the monitoring
officer has so far agreed with me any
comments or questions from Members or
have I missed anything henriet um chair
I am very sorry um I need to let you
know that the numbering on the protocol
has changed and instead of six in front
of all the bulling point we now have
four um it was updated uh late on Friday
um I do apologize I think you're working
but uh everything else Remains the Same
it's just a numbering so if we just have
a a 4.6 or 4.5 I do apologize I will
adjust as I go and you can correct me as
I go I see a hand raised I'm uncertain
as to whom that's from it doesn't have a
name
attached chair I do believe that's
councilor Osborne councelor
Osborne
okay before we go any further I'd like
to ask any members if they have any
declarable interest in the subject under
discussion that's members of the
committee itself councelor
grandon thank you chair yes I'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary
non-pecuniary local interest um as I do
know one of the bidders um I don't think
it will constitute a conflict of
interest I certainly wouldn't have
thought so unless the monitoring officer
thinks otherwise I'm happy for that to
be accepted thank
you okay so the first item on the agenda
today is uh to discuss the protocol this
protocol has been agreed with the lead
signatory uh councelor Owen and myself
and has been tabled for members in order
order to use the protocol it requires a
proposer and a second and an electronic
vote can I see if there's a proposer
please well I'm happy to propose it if
nobody else will do I have a seconder
councelor McLaren or councelor G well
we'll take counc I'm happy to second
that okay thank you very much for your
attention councelor G thank you as well
okay in that case we'll go to the
electronic vote and I'll ask henriet to
open that
now
your microphone may be on
counselor Council McLaren I think uh it
was sorry yeah it's
okay
I don't know about anybody else I've got
nothing coming up on mine no I can't see
the um protocol as being a blue line
anywhere
Henrietta we'll uh take a verbal vote if
that's
necessary we seem to have henriette's
microphone is turned off um anything I
haven't anything on there either
alist I do apologize chair um I think
the vote has is not there or it's
disappeared I'm happy to do a verbal
vote if a members is happy with that I
think we will just for Simplicity uh so
uh the motion is proposed and seconded
uh can we take a roll call vote please
certainly chair Council Dawson for
Council grandon four Council gold four
Council mcra four Council mcair
for coun Osborne for that's unanimous
chair thank you very much all in favor
members will have to excuse me as I
shift between two separate screens for
this process because the protocol itself
is the first section the protocol now
being agreed I have to introduce the
call-in itself and uh I ask members to
agree the scope of the call-in based on
the valid points made in the call-in
notice first first point was that
consideration of options that not all
options listed in the report were
discussed and debated and it was not
clear why the alternative options were
not chosen only bids B and F were
discussed however there were four other
bids why were they not
discussed the second item is the
presumption of openness when the
decision was taken there should have
been a presumption in favor of openness
the bid scoring Matrix which was on the
closed session you'll find that by the
way in appendix
d uh should have been an open session so
that the process was visible transparent
and open without the names and the price
bid included and the third point was a
matter of lack of clarity in two
sections a it was not made clear on what
areas of the whole Bell viw site were
open space so how could a decision be
made on balancing loss of open space and
the why was the red line not defined in
a clear
manner um I'd like members just by
General affirmation if they could agree
to the scope uh as presented within the
Callin any members want to speak against
the scope as proposed in that
Callin if we could all affirm that we
are happy with the scope we'll go to the
next step
where the lead signatory will be uh
invited to address the
meeting I happy with the scope as am
ion okay I'm happy with the scope y I'm
happy with the scope alist thank you
that's that's all we really need rather
than conducting another vote so uh the
scope being agreed I now ask the lead
signatory councelor Allison Owen uh if
she could present the reason for the
Callin and why the committee should
scrutinize this decision now this will
be for a maximum of 10 minutes which the
clerk will time the lead signatory may
choose to call other counselors from
those listed on the call-in notice but
the maximum amount of time will remain
10 minutes
collectively over to you I remind you
councelor ow before we start timing that
any mention of details in appendix d as
previously discussed would necessitate
us going into a vote for a closed
session okay coun Owen I think I've got
this um
covered right okay thank you um we have
called in the decision BCA 2044 relating
to the Bell View regeneration that was
heard at the cabinet meeting on the 11th
of March
2021 there were a number of reasons for
requesting this this decision to be
reviewed by the overview and scrutiny
committee the first reason for the call
in is because as as a council member I
was I was a able to attend the closed
session discussion and I was I was
expecting that each bid would be
discussed and the score reviewed against
each other only bids B and F were
discussed and they did not go through
the scoring and concentrated on the
preferred bid B I had assumed that they
would have started with reviewing the
scoring Matrix and how the scores were
decided the process felt very rushed and
needed more time time there were no
discussions about who had come up with
the system and how it had been weighted
and scored and if six bids came in then
six bids should have been
discussed it should have been clear why
the other bids bids were not
chosen based on these points and that
some of the scores did not make sense we
believe the bidden process should be
restarted we believe there should be a
clear understand understanding and
agreement of the scoring before any bids
are
considered we do not understand why the
scor Matrix could not have been made
open as to how it was calculated wait
and weighted The scor Matrix should have
been should have had the details of
biders removed so that this could have
been more made open and
transparent this would have helped to
show how the cabinet came to their
decision
this could also help future bids
including Community bids to understand
the requirements that Baba are looking
for to get the the best bids in there is
also a lack of clarity around some key
areas that we don't feel have been
properly considered and decisions have
been made with insufficient information
we understand that bab have to follow a
legal process for the disposal of the
open space the officers advised members
to weigh up the balance of loss of open
space against wider benefits there was
no clarification on what open space in
appendix a was being
lost it was advised that the process has
been followed by advertising in the
newspaper for a minimum of two weeks and
it's and it referen appendix a which is
the red lined land however there was no
assessment provided on how much of the
land Boba considered to be public open
space in appendix a there was also a
discussion about an extra 5 MERS of land
wanted from the house bidder it was
unclear if this extra land was going to
be given or or sold to the bidder and
there would be and there would be
further loss of open space that would
need to be
discussed the objections were in our
view not thoroughly debated and fully
understood councelor Osborne asked a
question if there were a deficit of open
space as raised in in the in the
objections and the answers given could
not confirm or deny and was quite
vague if you look on page 155 the agenda
supplement of to the cabinet papers it
shows that there is a minus
15.76% were mentioned as not being
included in the current assessment but
it's underwater for many months of the
year and not accessible for wheelchairs
this does not affect the current
shortfall of Park and Recreation land as
The Meadows are a part of a different
open space category given these points
we do not see how the cabinet members
could take a decision to dispose of open
space when they were not clear on what
it is or where it is we believe that
appendix a should clearly set out what
it what is open space before a decision
is made another issue was why the red
line was not defined in a clear manner
as it as it has a lot of impact in on
the decision
overall there was no clarification
whether the winning bid would be for the
land at appendix a the red line drawing
or whether the land will be required for
for for the bid to succeed and the bids
are subject to planning permission the
impact of the lack of clar clarity
includes The Terrace at the front of B
view is outside the red line and there
was confusion as to whether more land
would be negotiated at a later date the
resolution at 1.1 relates only to
appendix a at the red line drawing and
so surely bids outside the red line
would have to be reheard and and the
process started again the land at front
of the house is public open space and
would be subject to a new disposal
process the extra land would increase
the value of so the bid would need to be
renegotiated to reflect the extra land
given and could attract further bids as
most would want the house with the
Terrace given these key issues the
preferred bidder requires additional
land the marketing process should be
started again as a disposal agre agreed
by the cabinet was only for the land in
appendix a and nothing further we are
asking the overview and scrutiny
committee to review the decision made on
the basis of the points raised thank
you thank you very much councelor
Owen um I don't know where the would
like I don't know you have any does
henriet do you have any time left for
the signatories yes we have about three
minutes if councilor maber would like to
speak and that for that three
minutes thank you very much Mr chairman
I I hope you can you can see me okay um
I would just like to um support what
councelor Owen is particularly saying on
the negative aspect of open space there
is a matrix which should have been discl
closed I feel within these
papers of what is required per head of
population for open
space this is a very important part of
maintaining health and well-being as
well as the future of the town of
Sudbury and that is the clarification
that I feel uh overview and scrutiny
should ask for thank you
thank you very much councelor Ma are
there any other of the signatories who
wish to use the remaining
time if that isn't the case then I'll
now ask the cabinet members uh to
present the reasons why the decision was
taken by the cabinet these being
councelor Michael Holt Cabinet member
for economic growth and councelor David
Busby Cabinet member for assets and
Investments uh the time can be split
anywhere you like you have a maximum of
10 minutes uh I would assume councilor
Holt you're starting yes I'll give a
summary of um what uh what happened at
the cabinet meeting um right bvw site is
a long and complex history and the house
and the outd PO site have been or have
remained unused for a number of years
since the council resolved to dispose of
the site in
2013 some public uses of these areas
have been rovided including public swim
and fitness at the king fisher Leisure
Center which has just recently had a 2.4
million upgrade a new skate park and
multi-use gaming within the wider
Park this has been a costly upkeep for
the council as in the site and it's such
a key Gateway into the central area of
subury this has remained un
underutilized and it is not making any
contribution to the economic health of
the town and our vision Ambitions or
enabling further
investment no firm consensus on its
future and viability issues have led to
the site being dormant remain
dormant the latest marketing campaign
has sought to encourage fresh interest
and opportunities for this site to
progress during the cabinet meeting the
objections which were 32 in total to
this for the disposal of the house and
part of the old pool site were
considered objection grounds range from
loss of open space which has been
mentioned to planning matters to views
on the future use of the whole site or
just the house and on the marketing
period and
process the cabinet balanced and
carefully determined the grounds for the
objections with its wider approach for
the site for the best benefits of the
town in in deciding to progress with a
disposal the cabinet considered the six
bids received by informal Tender by the
12th February
2021 and after debate and careful
consideration a preferred bidder was
chosen although there was no obligation
to select any of the bids for
progression all proposals were subject
to planning and all bids received
included retaining or refurbishing or
indeed purpose in the house in some form
the bids all varied from a range of
Residential Care retirement and
Community
uses the cabinet also considered a
recommendation of diverting up to 100%
from any sale proceeds into the creation
of a new accessible Park entrance Cafe
toilets so that the park amenities and
local community and visitors would
benefit directly from any Capital
receipt
I mean that's the initial comment I'd
like to make um but obviously I'd like
to come back on individual questions as
we go through this process
CH Council
mcro my apologies I'd assumed my
microphone was live uh will councelor
Buzby be using the remaining part of the
minutes uh no chair
I I'm unable to support the cabinet in
this particular section I do think there
were flaws in the process so um I'm
happy to comment in the debate section
okay you'll be available for questioning
then councelor
Busby yes chair thank you very much
indeed so at this point the cabinet
members now being finished I'd um last
like to invite members of the committee
only if they may if they'd like to ask
any questions of either the lead
signatory or either of the cabinet
members for further
information over to you members please
use the raiseed hand
function councelor
dwson uh in light of uh what councilor
bosby just said I just wonder whether
perhaps he might be able to Enlighten us
what he believes are the flaws
in
this quite
simply okay we're talking about the
process here yes as far as I'm concerned
before you make a decision you try and
uh gather as much information as you
possibly can to make sure that you're
making an informed decision
um we had
the addendum to the agenda was
440 pages
long You' have thought that would have
been plenty long enough to include all
of the Salient information unfortunately
didn't include the six the details of
the six bids and we weren't allowed to
access those papers during the private
section um and my view without that we
couldn't make an informed decision on
the bids because we didn't have the
detail of them and there were a number
of questions related to the bids that
needed to be cleared before in my view
we could make the right
decision and what were these questions
sorry well primarily about the outline
um the area that was put up for sale was
quite clearly marked by the red line
which ran close to the um the
house next to the bay window and then
down the site uh but the one of the bids
the one that was chosen actually
had a red line that was further into the
park than that approximately 5 MERS
extra it took an extra piece of land at
the top of the of the park and an extra
piece of land at the bottom and that
would have made made quite a bit of
difference to what was being proposed so
I just felt that we
were accepting a
bid that wasn't
feasible because they the bidder had
stated that they needed the extra
land and that wasn't for sale that
wasn't for offer so I just thought we've
got ourselves into a into a pickle by
making this
decision Council Dawson um well just
coming back I mean at the end of the day
uh this property I mean was left to the
people of
Sudbury I mean I'm unclear uh presumably
we are legally allowed to sell
it um looking at the bigger
picture you know what difference to you
would five meters make in all
honesty it seems not a terribly good
reason to not support you know
I think at this point councelor Dawson
if with your permission yeah I think it
might be helpful if councelor HT could
answer or at least address some of the
points raised by councelor Busby that
also uh would speak to your question
would you be satisfied with that yeah
thank you if that's okay with you
councelor Busby I think it's only
reasonable Council Holt I was too
wondering um what reasons there were for
not there not being further discussion
of bid details such as the ones
mentioned is that
okay yeah I mean uh Council bu you
mentions the uh big details I mean the
um the whole objective of the cabinet
meeting was for not necessarily to
discuss the bid uh details as such as in
the the makeup of it but actually to to
carry out the uh recommendation of
officers in the
paper so at no point really was there um
a planned opportunity to go through the
bidding process this um as I say was
presented in the paper as the Matrix
that was in the uh private section um
and moving on to the red line um
comments the red line is the red line
now if biders and there were more than
one who potentially wanted to buy more
land but the land in the
s123 um
is purely the red line and um there is
no other land that we can sell outside
that line without going through the
whole process again and to my knowledge
we have no intention of doing so there
have been one or two applicants who I I
say have wanted more land but it's quite
clear in the
s123 the red line is the red line and
it's mentioned I think in in point three
of the um calling as well I mean a red
line know clearer than a red line it's
quite defined it's quite accurate um and
that is the portion of land that is for
disposal um so there really I can't
remember what else Dave mentioned but
um the bidding process was um as I
say I thought every member had the
opportunity do
discuss um if members don't wish to
partake in the debate then that's
entirely up to them I mean we have a
presentation here of over 400 papers
that all members cabinet members have
read and also um bab district council
members have read and is available to
the public the vast majority of all that
apart from the private section and even
though we do encourage um members to
come along to Cabinet meetings we can't
force them to engage in debate um there
was two or three I think who who signed
this calling who were present and a
couple of them certainly spoke which was
which was welcomed
but um for future debates um we do
encourage more members to come along I
think the information in the paper is
very
comprehensive and probably far more than
what we've had previous times and all
the way during this um process we have
consulted our legal team we have got
advice from them as to what we could
include and could not include in an open
paper and that had to go into a private
paper we were very conscious that we
want to put as much information as
possible into the public domain but we
take our advice as you do chair as well
with overview and scrutiny we take our
advice from our legal team from a
monitoring officer and we followed the
guidance that we were given to the to
the dot and um the paper was as much as
we could put out in the public domain
there's been a lot of talk about the
Matrix um and the scoring of it but I
say that wasn't up for debate at the
cabinet
meeting thank you thank you very much
councilor halt I noticed that uh f d
haml who is the assistant director for
economic growth and regeneration and
therefore the relevant officer had her
hand briefly raised and there will be an
opportunity to ask officers questions in
the next section of the protocol um if
Fiona is happy to wait till that point
unless it's absolutely necessary that
she speak now I'll move then to to the
next person with the hand raised which
which is uh councelor
G there questions for the lead signatory
and cabinet members yes thank you Mr
chair um it does seem to me with with
this red line um that if some of the
bids had put in a bid that required 5
meters more of of the Parkland than
others then the bids weren't like for
like were
they that that would be I think my
question probably to councelor Halt um
that that clearly bids have got to be
like for like and if if some of the bids
were requesting an extra 5 meters they
weren't like for like were they I think
my other point would be
um that it's not so much which of the
bids was chosen in my mind one of the
key questions is were all six
discussed um and I've also got a
question as to who who um did The Matrix
who is responsible ible for actually
creating that Matrix that's another
question I've got um I think that's
probably all for
now okay councelor Holt yeah I think
that's addressed to
you yes I think so I I think in Far
times of the report perhaps when we
speak to officers we can address the
report construction later but we'll see
I mean the red line as I've said was
drawn from the marketing and the s123
notice it's consistent all the way along
with both of those the boundary uh was
also drawn in this way to ensure
sufficient land was retained from the
old swiming pool site and to create the
new park entrance and retaining walls
given the levels and across the whole
site um the red line as drawn did not
prevent biders from bidding for a wider
site and a number of parties did seek to
include land outside the red boundary um
but that was up to them um we are quite
defined of the area that is up for sell
within that notice and that is all the
land that we intend to sell with this
bidding purchase and subsequent any
development that goes on that is the red
line I can't be more specific that that
is the area that is up for disposal so
did all the biders know that they could
have put in a bid with a bit of extra
that wasn't within the the red line were
they all aware that that was something
they could do well it seems that some
have obviously done that um I not sure
if if we made it clear that to any
bidder that you could bid for the whole
site all of the park or whatever but um
most people end during this sort of
process will just bid within the defined
line that they require um they if they
want to put in a um if if they're trying
to show or illustrate a project that
they want to fit in a site and they
stretch those red lines that's their
problem it's not our problem the land
that's being sold is clearly defined
by the red line and that is the only
piece of land that we are looking to
dispose
of okay I think we've gone as far as we
can with that is that satisfactory to
you councelor
g i i I think for the moment yes I I
think I think I just wonder whether
there was some haziness then it just
seems to be a little strange um that
some of the bids were sort of bidding
for bits that were almost outside the
remit um and and if they are if they
were bidding for bits that were outside
that the redline remit um then perhaps
the remit needed to be a little bit
tighter could that perhaps be addressed
with the officer's questioning yes in
the next section that might address your
concern councelor grandon you're up
next thank you chair um I'd like to ask
councelor Owen um what her objective is
with regard to the Callin what she would
like to achieve with this um because um
if there is a
clear um successful
bidder
um it seems to me that the outcome might
be the same anyway so what is councelor
Owen's objective in in bringing this
call in
please thank you councilor grandom I I I
want it all looked at and done properly
I want um everything to be open and
transparent so I would like um the
objective is to for everyone to see how
they made the bid how they actually made
it I've I've got the objections in here
so to make sure the um scoring Matrix
were properly
considered um to make sure everything
was discussed
properly
um make sure the the loss of open spaces
assessed
properly and make sure the objections
were thoroughly heard I just think
everything was so rushed and I I would
like to see it go back again even if
they do make the same Choice it it's
it's not the choice it's how it was done
so even if they made the same choice I
would like to see it done
properly I very helpful thank you okay
thank you very much councelor ow and
councelor grandon councel McLaren you
have your hand
raised I I'm come back to you later
councelor
H thank you chair um when I was
reviewing the papers councelor halt I
was trying to having looked at the
previous proposal for a hotel falling
through in
June um I was trying to determine what
the rules were around the bidding
process what time span is there from the
first advert to the uh close of the
bidding
process when I looked at the information
it gave me the closing date which
originally was the 22nd of January but
it didn't give a starting date what what
is your understanding of the length of
time for the bidding
process I'll refer to owner for the
start date of the bidding process of I
made because I can't remember off the
top of my head when that was um the s123
notice went in just before Christmas and
was run I think for a total of three
weeks but the bidding process was
extended by a couple of weeks but Fiona
have you got the exact
dates I'm just looking for that Michael
I think it was either the uh I think it
was something like the 14th of December
so it was a couple of weeks before
Christmas that the um I think it is in
the um it's in the confidential paper
which obviously we can't talk about um
so we might want to come back to that
later but it is set out in the marketing
the marketing
information so originally we went from
the 14th to the
22nd uh and that included the Christmas
period yes that's correct um there's
obviously no no right answer in terms of
marketing of of properties on an
informal tender basis um the reason we
extended it is because as expected we
had good interest but the government
also announced further lockdown measures
and in order to be able to conduct or
offer sufficient viewings um we extended
the deadline but it you know thinking
about Christmas and the
pandemic uh was this really the best
time of the year to begin it a bid in
process I think to be honest Council
Caren the timing was um just where the
the the the process was if you s what I
mean we were considering the disposal um
and we wanted to go ahead um with it and
it was taken that um the disposal notice
going in just before Christmas was
acceptable and it gave um the bidders
opportunities to um put in their bids I
think there was over 60 odd sites I
think um f that actually where this was
um viewed and there was considerable
interest in the site other than the just
the six biders we received so I think um
it's clear that this was um you may
think a bad time to do it but quite the
contrary we had a lot of interest and um
we had um you know six bits in the end
that um I think proves that timing
wasn't really an issue here can I just
uh intervene here briefly because all
these questions that councilor Mclaren
has so usefully raised are in fact
covered um in some depth in appendix D
which describes the entire marketing
summary bid process and the time scales
to carry out any further discussion of
these usefully we would need to go into
closed session thank you um I'm happy to
do that if that is what members wish to
do um because it is entirely relevant to
your questions or it could be done at
some later point in the meeting what I'd
like to do for the moment is go to the
other questions uh for the hands raised
that we have and then maybe come back to
this specific matter of the bidding
process is that satisfactory to you
councelor McLaren that's fine chairman
thank you very much uh councelor
Dawson um yes this is a question really
for Council Hulk coming back to what he
said um the Strategic
priorities are linked for this matter
and in 5.34 of them are there which were
used as part of the evaluation process
firstly can you um tell us what the
other
two uh strategic priorities are that you
took into consideration because they're
not in the paper and
secondly were those
two taken into
account um because it's is part of the
Strategic corporate plan which you
obviously oversee sorry what part of the
paper was that please Council if you
look at
5.3 what page is that please oh sorry
page uh I got page number at the
bottom oh I don't have page numbers I'm
afraid M why it's wherever five in the
paper it's 5.3 yeah this would be uh
this would be in the cabinet papers
regarding strategic priorities link to
this matter include a rejuvenating our
vibrant Market towns B driving
attractive sustainable and connected
communities I'm reading this out just
for convenience San uh a robust
Financial strategy and recognizing the
need to provide appropriate housing for
an aging population so these are linked
to the matter right and if I just yes
but it goes on to say there are six
corporate and it's outlined four so what
I'm asking is were the other two can you
say what those two were and were they
applied as part of the evaluation
process to our
corporate
plan item strategic priorities are did
those are the two strategic priorities
do you know what they are I mean they're
not in here councel Dawson I'm unclear
as to where this is going since the
matter and well because in the back of
the plan if you look at appendix t d I
don't want to go too much detail but the
evaluation quite clearly when it comes
to the scoring the quality fact factors
outline what strategic priorities are
okay and four of those are outlined in
that case we would we would I'm afraid
any reference to the cont I finish the
moment councel Dawson I'm just G have to
stop you there I'm sorry but any any
discussion of reference from the the
open public papers to the reserved
matters paper um necessitates discussion
of the reserved matters um I'm not quite
convinced I'll be frank with you that
the Strategic consideration is relevant
to what is fundamentally a procedural
call-in um which is this is what this is
uh it's about the procedure undertaken
by the cabinet and I've got a feeling
that strategy is at a higher level than
the matter under
consideration um that's my only thought
and I'm just trying to keep us focused
on the nature of the call in itself this
is this seems to me to be dragging
something else in okay can I come
back
sorry I'm here to review this would you
like me to come back to this matter at a
later date because clearly this is in
the front in the public part of the
paper and I I and that's why I'm not
alluding to the evalu would you like me
to come back to it yes you have referred
though to the the confidential papers so
but I I'm not sure the Strategic matter
is what we are we are here to consider
the calling itself under the points
raised in the calling they themselves
they themselves councelor Dawson do not
raise um a strategic matter as you
outline so therefore that's outside the
remit of this Committee in my view sorry
well in my view um with all due respect
is not that yeah but I mean I I you can
you can say so councelor Dawson but I
mean think we'll take advice from
monitoring officer what is we leave it
to the monitoring officer to determine
this I'm determining I'm determining
that I think this might be beyond the
remit of this Callin C uh Emily can you
help us here yes chair thank you um the
committee's agreed the scope of the
Callin um by looking at the three
call-in points um at the very start of
the uh discussion of this item the
calling points do not talk about the uh
scoring Matrix in terms of what elements
were scored or the waiting it simply
talks about whether whether or not the
scoring Matrix should have been included
in the public part of the papers
therefore the overview and scrutiny
committee should not be looking at um
the detail of the scoring matrix it's
the question of whether it or not it
should have been published which is is
under scrutiny as part of the call
in is that okay councilor Dawson well
yes I'll come back I think at a later
date if you don't mind as I say if if it
comes back to strategy it may not be
necessary councilor Bor you're next to
speak yeah thank you Mr chairman and
good afternoon Council Hulk um my
question is about the bids was one of
the bids requesting to go outside the
red line one of the community bids
please um I'm not sure I'm really
permitted to discuss that to be honest
Emily what do you you think
[Music]
I don't know if Fiona can add anything
here we got some advice on that from
Emily Mr chairman if I if I could come
in please um again the the scrutiny
committee's remit is not to discuss the
content of the bids or the Merit of the
bids it's about the process so actually
whether or not any of the bids um we're
inside or outside of the red line is is
essentially a moot point the point um
rais in the call in is was the red line
clear
enough thank you chair okay thank you
very much uh does that answer your
question councelor
Osborne yes it does thank you very much
Mr chairman thank you thank you
councelor grandon your hand is
raised thank you
chair um I'm not sure if I've missed
something but one of the main points
that um the Lee signatory discussed
um for her calling was um the
consideration of
options um and um it's asked were only
bids B and F
discussed um I don't know if I've missed
it but were only bids B and F
discussed um well I certainly made it
clear in the meeting that we had six
bids on the table um now through
recollection I don't remember if all of
those bids were discussed I don't think
they all were in depth in depthly
discussed on the day but um as I said
before all members had all this um
presentation all the paperwork given to
them prior to as would always be the
case they should have obviously have
read that digested it and if there was
questions or debate to be considered or
taken on the day that was up to them to
initiate that debate but all the
information
that they needed and required was
presented to them beforehand and as I
alluded to you know the debate is is
self initiating it starts with members
um and if they didn't feel they needed
to discuss some of those bids that's
entirely up to them but I consider that
every opportunity was given to all the
bids to be discussed in a fair way and I
think that's that's all I can say on
that matter do you think all cabinet
members um themselves examined all the
bids because they were in the papers I'd
like to think so Council grant that that
is their role and as their duty to to to
read the papers and and come prepared to
to a meeting whether it be a cabinet
meeting or for any of us to attend any
meeting to be prepared by reading the
papers beforehand and being uh fully
aware of what's uh going to be
discussed I think anybody could have
been forgiven for not reading through
the entire infrastructure plan till the
year 20 33 but I think the main content
of the report that we have in printed in
front of us would be absolutely
essential for all members and and we'd
assume all members I'm just finishing up
we' assume all members would do so in
any meeting uh and we have to make that
assumption what is in the report forms
part of the meeting now I see Hands
raised from councilor's Busby um I I'm
going to be able to invite questions
from officers and other members of
cabinet later so so if councelor Davis
would like to uh wait for that councelor
Busby did you have something you wish to
say yeah a couple of things
um we made a decision based on the
Matrix because that was the only
information that was available to
us but on reflection the information
contained therein was based on a flawed
premise what we don't know was what some
of the bidders would bid for the
restricted land they put a price on
their bid based on the land that they
had
specified
now the price of uh their bid was quite
heavily scored in the
Matrix and that's figure in the Matrix
could be considerably
wrong if they were restricted to the
sail land as we now specify we don't
know what they were prepared to offer
for the for the red line that was up for
sale because that was never asked of
them okay so the problem was that the
decision was made made only on The
Matrix because we weren't allowed to
bring the papers in from the
bids but the scoring of the Matrix would
have been
flawed okay thank you for the point um I
think we'll have to come back to that
because I'm not sure it's directly
connected it it's connected with one
part of the calling which is whether it
should have been done in public session
or not we haven't aren't actually
discussing in the Callin the nature of
the Matrix itself that is not uh part of
the scope of this meeting councilor
McLaren thank you chair uh I'm not sure
that my question is going to be as part
of the process but um we'll soon tell
you don't worry I know right um looking
at all the objection question s that
were in your paper councelor Halt and
there was quite a lot and a lot to
read can I just ask if there was any
discussion within the cabinet to go out
to some sort of public consultation or
discussion with the is that not relevant
Council mlar that's not relevant to the
scope of this committee uh for
information I can remember the meeting
and uh there was discussion in fact
there was considerable discussion of the
whole question of the nature of all the
objections but that is not within the
scope of this meeting oh sorry thank you
that's okay I think I think it's very
difficult when we're dealing with
scrutiny normally we take a wider view
here we are asked to take quite specific
view which is why we discuss scope and
then that fact that we are dealing with
a procedural matter here uh councelor
grandon if do you have something you
wish to add because I would like to move
to the next section which is questions
of officers and other members of the
cabinet councelor grandon um yes I I
don't know whether this should be to
officers or councelor halt but um point
two of the call-in um notice was the
presumption of open openness and I
wondered whether it was a cabinet
decision or an officer decision that the
matrics should be discussed in closed
session
I believe councelor Grand and I can
answer that question it would be defined
by
law where commercially confidential
information was involved officers would
automatically inform members that such
should be considered commercially
confidential that's just for
information I think at this so in a way
that the the law then am I right in in
summarizing that then by saying that
point two the presumption of openness
the cabinet in fact had no option but
to discuss the Matrix in closed session
whereas the that that point of the
Callin is asking why couldn't that be
called um discussed in Open Session am I
right in saying you're saying that they
had no option it had to be done that way
because of the law I think councelor
grandon you've raised a very interesting
point here and in fact I think that
takes us to the next section of the
meeting because this does require
officer input and what I'm proposing can
I just say something you you may but I'm
I'm I'm proposing we go and to to allow
this to be dealt with okay um that we go
to the questions of officers and other
members of the cabinet okay councelor
Owen as the lead signatory do you have
something you wish to add can can I just
answer that please because um it's I'm
going to go back to my notes Here um the
reason why sorry I've got to get the
reason why I said about the openness I
did state that in my um in my notes that
um the reason why I think it should have
been openness maybe the money side
shouldn't have been on there and maybe
the um the biders shouldn't have been on
there but everything else could have
been in openness could have been seen
and there's no to say that I would be a
very key point of it can I can I can I
ask everybody just for a moment to
hold there is a point here which I think
is entirely relevant it concerns The
Matrix um and we're not going to discuss
the details of the Matrix but the
question here it seems to me must be
whether the Matrix is possible to be
considered in part or whether it must be
if it's going to be completely open or
completely closed is it possible POS in
fact to split the Matrix up and what I'd
like to do is now to move towards
addressing that with officer support and
information so I'd like to move to the
next section which is that members can
now ask questions of officers and other
members of the cabinet if they're
present and I believe that uh Fiona du
haml might be well equipped to answer
some of the questions that members have
raised
previously members Katherine would you
like to
start I'd like to return
to point two on the call-in notice about
the presumption of openness and whether
the Matrix should have been in the open
session or otherwise and also whether
the Matrix could have
been a proper Matrix if it didn't
include the figures because it seems to
me figures are are one of the most
Central points of it really could I
could you answer that please yes
certainly so um the scoring Matrix uh
any scoring matrix it's highly highly
unlikely that that would be available in
public session um as it would Prejudice
any future discussions um with the with
the bidder and any Challenge from any
unsuccessful biders um if all of the
scoring is exposed um it it really uh
undermines the commercial sensitivity
process um in terms of uh the second
part of your question which was around
uh whether the amounts should be in
again um due to com commercial
sensitivity um it would be highly
unlikely to publish uh the amounts for
all the biders because it undermines any
future process so uh whilst we're
looking at the decision on the night we
also have to look at um what the future
discussions may be um and uh obviously
at the appropriate time all of that
information can be made public public
but um during the uh during the
negotiation stage and and I would remind
uh this committee that this is not a
formal tender process either it's a land
transaction therefore it's an informal
process um and the scoring Matrix was um
uh or rather the um assessment of the
bids and the development of the scoring
Matrix was done with the council's
procurement lead um and all fully signed
off by both her and the monitoring
officer and our our legal team so it has
been checked and rechecked in terms of
due process I have two follow-up
questions please go ahead would thank
you um would the Matrix be a matrix
without the figures would it you know
could that be possible and also can you
tell me what the difference is between
an informal and
formal bid
please what what the difference is to
the whole process that yes so so the
scoring Matrix um again I think we're in
Open session at the moment so I can't
really go through the details of the
scoring process it might be possible to
to leave that to a to a later time um in
terms of the difference between formal
and informal um there I I don't have the
list of uh differences but essentially
there's more negotiation allowed around
the informal tender process and actually
uh I could just pick up briefly chair
the the item around the red line which
is um you know a number of bids actually
um asked for land outside of the red
line the decision we asked cabinet to
make was of the land within the red line
and um any any negotiation that happens
um after cabinet um may may happen but
the decision on the night was strictly
around land being sold within the red
line thank you I think that helps a
little bit um I'd just like to raise one
question with Fiona if I may which is
would it be possible ible to dis to make
uh a partial Matrix public would it not
in fact be the case that uh anybody with
a little bit of nouse could take the
information that was presented and make
their own
deductions whether correct or incorrect
but make their own deductions on the
basis of a partial Matrix which uh would
itself have been um breaking commercial
confidentiality yes I mean taking the
advice we took we provided as much
information as possible into the open
report and that goes in respect of the
marketing process and the biders um and
also around the uh other part of the
report which is around objections and
you'll notice that um every effort was
made in that report which is why it's so
long to put as much information in in as
possible and it was the firm advice of
officers led by yourself that the Matrix
could not be published in any form would
that be a correct statement
uh yes as I said there is a form of
Matrix in the public document there's a
table um but that's that's sufficient
information for the purposes of
commercial confidentiality I believe
Emily uh when she talks later on may
wish to I think that's very important we
will be coming to that uh that statement
that's uh 4.4 the outline of the bid
proposals received um which I I think
this actually rests very closely to the
nature of the call in um regarding that
okay does any other member have any
questions for officers councelor Dawson
your hand is
raised um yes as minut perhaps Fiona can
answer this as part of the
process um you've recommended that 100%
of this goes back into ensure the
creation of the new
entrance and clearly there's a disparity
between what that entrance is going to
cost and what it's going to sell for in
the figures here so is that difference
going to be there's no mention of where
that uh 400,000 is going is it going
back to the entr can we can we not can
we not refer to figures please sorry
that that difference the lump sum of
money is quite is that are we making a
guarantee here is part of the sale
process that 100% of the sale figure is
all being plowed back into that entrance
for toilets and
cafes it is in fact up to I believe yes
no it says up to 100% yes the reason the
reason it was up to is because uh we're
still finalizing the costs for the park
entrance and we have some funding bids
in that may reduce that may reduce the
the the amount required but it obviously
the um work is still in progress in
terms of detailed design and costings
for the park entrance and the related
facilities I mean what why I'm wondering
is is this large disparity going to get
pushed off into somewhere else
else I think Sean the 100% is is a call
parking the 100% is a commitment from
the cabinet to reinvest whatever money
comes forward for the side of the land
back into the
park I'm sorry just on that point
Council H I believe the what might might
happen to any any emerging Surplus was
discussed within cabinet was it
not yes and and what what was the result
of that discussion what was the proposed
solution for uh any surplus that might
emerge should there be a surplus it was
given that a steer would be to to retain
that money for developing the park and
to retain it for for for sub thank you
is that I mean that's quite important
could we note that to be part of um you
know one of the conditions or
recommendations it's not within our
scope or remit and in fact it was and
fact part of the cabinet um discussion
so I think it can be taken as red um you
know on the basis of that's what they
said that people change things change
and it might not get plowed back in
there again I think the fact that it's
been mentioned here is that we have the
opportunity in a future date to call
members of the cabinet to account on
that matter okay so I think that's
that's part of our job um any other
questions for officers and other members
of the
cabinet
okay thank you very much members I I
think we've gone as far as we can on
this um I have a question sorry I've got
my hand up I'm sorry councelor grandon I
saw that I was about to suggest some
other course of action go ahead please
sorry sorry thank
you um yes I I don't know who it's best
for me to address this to but um I I
just want to look again at um the
Callin and um the signature lead
signatory did say that um it was not
made clear on what areas of the whole
Bel site were open space so how could a
decision be made on balancing loss of
open space could someone um one of you
answer that please thank
you yes I can I can pick that up um we
have put we did put quite a lot of
information in the report itself about
this because it's not clear that is no
one clear piece of legislation that says
this is how you define public open space
it's defined in a number of ways and we
took um advice both from shared legal
and from pinsent Mason's lawyers to to
help Define this in the report um public
open space can be defined in a number of
ways um one way is within the council's
local plan um which we did include in
the report in terms of the amount and if
you take uh that assessment there's a
very small amount of public open space
in the actual red line which is more
than provided by the creation of the new
park entrance or more than rovided sorry
um however um it it's also there's case
law to suggests that um uh historic use
of or historic public use of land is
also to be taken into account and
current use of of land so if we take the
assumption that the swimming pool site
has in the past be uh been used for
public open space or or public use then
that could also be included as public
open space even though it's not defined
in our local plan um so like I say it's
not it's not there's not an easy yes or
no or black and white answer um but
that's where we directed cabinet to make
sure that they looked at the balance of
the opportunities coming forward for
regeneration versus The Lost of
potential uh public open space um and
also mitigation that's been carried out
in the past in terms of reprovision for
example of swimming facilities elsewhere
in Sudbury um so sorry that's a bit of a
waffly answer but it's not a there's not
a clear yes or no answer I'm afraid okay
thank you thank you very much fer I
would like just to follow up a little
bit on that because on the I recall
there was extensive discussion on the
definition of open space uh within the
cabinet meeting can you tell me whether
that was done in the open session or the
closed
session I think that was done in the
open session I recall so I recall and it
was lengthy along with a lengthy session
on the on the legal position position
regarding Section 1 123 thank you very
much um at this point members I find
myself asking whether we wish to go
since there's been a lot of questioning
on the nature of the Matrix whether at
this point members wish to go into close
session to discuss the contents of
appendix
D um I would just like to know if
anybody would like to propose that and
second it and then we could vote upon it
or whether we're happy to continue with
the protocol as is outlined
currently I'm happy to move forward with
the debate thank you anybody else like
to speak on
this well I don't see anybody proposing
that we go into part two so we shall
move on then uh uh committee members do
you have any further questions in light
of any new information to anybody
involved in the
meeting in that case I'll now ask the
cabinet member or members followed by
the lead signatory to provide a summary
of the respective cases
and each summary will be allowed five
minutes uh that would mean I think we
start with you councelor
Holt thank you chair um well it's been
quite clear this afternoon or it is
afternoon isn't it that um I think we've
answered all the questions that you
presented re the three questions the
consideration of the options the
presumption of openness and the lack of
clarity um it's to me clear that during
this whole process we we have followed
our legal advice
and and have tried to be as transparent
as possible and that we in doing that
have presented a very very large
document um which members were able to
read through and and obviously at the
cabinet meeting itself debate I'm happy
that um that process resulted in a clear
and uh positive outcome in that um
the preferred option b um was was the
one Chosen and it's the one we hope to
go forward with I personally think as I
say we have done everything we can and
um I'm not sure if there's any more that
we could have done to be honest it's
quite clear from from the evidence given
today that the
Matrix um wasn't uh to be shared and
that was on the advice given to us I can
understand certain frustration possibly
that it wasn't but we are in a
commercial transaction here and I think
we have to respect the law and the
advice we're given uh during this
process the open space as um f has
alluded to is is questionable um but um
it is hard to Define but we've been
honest and open with that all the way
through um
and that's all I've got to say really CH
I I think everything that has been said
today hopefully as answer some questions
and not drawn out
anymore thank you very much councelor
Holt I don't know if councelor Busby
wished to speak as a other Cabinet
member well only to say really that
we're going through all this exercise um
and we did on the 11th and we've
actually got not got ourselves any
further forward than if we' not made the
decision there's a lot of negotiation
still to take place with the preferred
bidder and possibly with other biders
and I feel that we should have done that
before we were put into a position to
make a decision based on flawed
information I just think the
process that's
not the process points are the words we
are already considering yes thank you
councilor Busby um at this point then
I'll ask councelor Owen if you'd like to
use your five minutes for your summary
of your case for the call
in councelor Owen thank you very much
chair thank you right oh sorry about
that there right um in the summary we
are asking over overview and scrutiny to
review the decisions made taken into
account the points we've raised the key
issues being the scoring Matrix was not
properly considered not all of the bids
were discussed the scoring Matrix was
not open and transparent the loss of
open space was not assessed properly the
objections were not thoroughly heard
cabinet agreed to sell the land within
the red line at appendix a but the
bidder wants extra land that this should
be part of remarketing process as it
affects the bids that came in and the
value of the land overall the whole
cabinet decisions makings process was
rushed hang on a minute I think I might
have something else as
well uh right
how much weight is the scoring process
was given
to is it hard to see how retirement
living oh sorry I shouldn't have said
that what evidence is there suggest that
we need for another BL right okay I
won't say that that's fine because
there's certain things in
confidentiality I can't say I realize
that okay thank you for your forbearance
councelor Owen I think we get into
specifics uh because we're looking at
the process here okay if all uh the both
sign signatur and the cabinet members
have completed their summaries uh this
would be the point at which I will now
ask for the monitoring officer to bring
forward their evidence statement I
believe this is actually quite crucial
for our determinations today and will'll
very much address the issues and the um
possible courses of action we are able
and I stress able to take uh over to
Emily U please
thank you chair um there are a couple of
points that I would like to advise uh
the committee of and I have circulated
this um statement to committee members
albe it um very early this morning um as
part of the tabled paper so um I was
planning to make a verbal statement but
I did want members to have the the
written statement as well chair so as
part of the call in process I'm actually
required to advise the overview and
scrutiny committee as to whether the
decision that has been taken by cabinet
is consistent with the agreed policy
framework and budget of the
council firstly however I think it is
important to confirm that the decision
to consider disposal of a site following
a notice under Section 123 of the Local
Government Act
1972 and to agree the sale of the site
to a bidder for best consideration is an
executive function as defined by the
local authorities functions and
responsibilities England regulation
2000 therefore the cabinet has acted
within the powers afforded to it by
legislation and confirmed by the
council's
Constitution I'm also satisfied that the
decision made by the cabinet is
consistent with a number of the
council's major policies including the
recently adopted strategic assets
management plan and is within the agreed
budget I would like to reiterate points
made by colleagues um and cabinet
members around the legal advice that has
been been sought the uh assistant
director for economic development and
regeneration has taken comprehensive
legal advice from both external sector
experts and from the in-house legal team
this advice covered the process for the
section23 notice and the consideration
of objections and also the mechanism for
evaluating the bids for the
site chair if I may I'd also like to
offer some procedural thought thoughts
on the uh consideration of the various
uh Callin
grounds so the first of those was
consideration of the options the calling
contends that insufficient consideration
was given to each of the bids as only
bids B and F were discussed by cabinet
members during the meeting itself I
actually advised the cabinet that its
role was not to evaluate each of the
bids the cabinet was required to
consider whether due process had been
followed in undertaking the evaluation
and then consider whether or not it
agreed with the recommended bid
therefore there was no procedural
requirement for the cabinet to mention
each of the bids individually during its
debate the second calling ground is the
presumption of openness the calling
suggests that the scoring Matrix should
have been included in the open part of
the report in order to satisfy the
presumption of openness in the
decision-making process which of course
is part of the execu
Arrangements it would be highly
irregular to publish the score in Matrix
for competitive bids or tenders Not only
would this potentially compromise the
commercial interests of the biders but
would also Prejudice the ability of the
unsuccessful bidders to challenge the
process I therefore would not support
the publication of the scoring Matrix in
the open part of the report and as
officers have alluded to in their
evidence today this was not supported in
the legal advice
taken in all other respects the cabinet
has taken every effort to ensure as much
of the report as possible was made
public and that a large section of the
debate was undertaken in the open part
of the meeting therefore I am satisfied
that there was a presumption of openness
in dealing with this
item the Final Ground is around the lack
of clarity and the call-in contends that
there was a lack of clarity about the
definition of open space and the red
line defining the area of the site that
had been marketed
I agree with the statements made by
officers and the cabinet member today
and I am satisfied that there was a
sufficient definition of open space as
set out in paragraph 4.13 of the cabinet
report not withstanding the challenges
that have been described today in
actually um defining open space in
accordance with with various pieces of
legislation I also consider that the
plan of the site which was included as
as appendix a to the cabinet report was
absolutely
clear the latter point so that the
redline plan was also subject of a
specific point of clarification during
the cabinet debate to which officers
provided answers and therefore I um am
of the view that due consideration was
given to that Clarity around the plan
during the cabinet
debate chair that concludes uh the
evidence that I would like to present to
to the committee but I'm very happy to
answer any questions thank
you yes I'd like to ask members if they
have any questions for the monitoring
officer on those points they seem to me
to be quite pertinent I I want not going
to include the uh Cabinet member in this
instance members of the committee only
please this is to help you make your
determination are there any hands
raised no I yes I see one at last hang
on a minute I'm having difficult
difficult
difficulty accessing that part of the
screen I can't yet see who it is if you
could make yourself known to me I see a
hand but I don't know who chair that is
councilor Osborne thank you very much
councelor
Osborne thank you Mr chairman um it's a
it's a question really of of uh asking
our monitoring officer was is she
satisfied and do we know that every
member of that cabinet actually read
their um documents that were presented
to them uh it's obviously I know a lot
of a lot of paperwork but is she
satisfied that every member of that
cabinet knew knew what was uh going
forward from that uh presentation thank
you chair I think that's somewhat of a
difficult it's an impossible question if
I might might be honest councelor
Osborne it's impossible to ask if we can
be certain if every member has read
everything that's placed in front of
them but I think in definition we make
the assumption that that is the case as
we would in a planning meeting or indeed
any other meeting I personally believe
that you could be excused for not having
read the infrastructure delivery plan
for the next een years because I don't
believe that to have been strictly
relevant but I think I think we'll just
call that a moot point if you don't mind
councelor Osborne no no I just come back
I'd like to thank
Michael Hol for for an answer that he
gave previously uh but it was just a
concern that um you know there are a lot
of there are a lot of papers and it was
just a concern that and to ensure that
you had members there that actually had
read those things they're not you know
they're always going to say I hope
they're always going to say yes I did um
but it you know it they're being they're
being criticized for not reading all
their paperwork well you know it
shouldn't be and I don't think it's for
anybody to decide uh what um members of
any committee whether it be a cabinet or
a committee as to what they are must
debate otherwise you'd insist that they
discuss every single paragraph on every
single paper and our meetings would last
for 12 hours so I don't think that's
practical now I'm aware of some other
cabinet members who just can I just come
back C Osborne yes go ahead you've got
two cabinet members there can I can I
ask that um you asked them that same
questions did they read I I was going to
say there was an opportunity for other
cabinet members to answer questions I'm
quite prepared to to take questions to
those other cabinet members but none
have previously been forthcoming so if
they are forthcoming now and you wish to
ask questions of the other cabinet
members would that be allowable
Emily CH it's entirely your discretion I
just wondered if I could make a comment
um just in response to the question
raised by councilor Osborne um of of
course I'm not going to uh attempt to
ever uh uh guess what councilors may or
may not have read um because of course
it's the individual um responsibility
and duty of each counselor to be
properly prepared um and that will vary
on on each different councilor's
preparation and their background
knowledge to the subject um what I will
say however is that I was present during
the whole of the cabinet meeting and the
comments that I heard
um made by cabinet members certainly
indicated that they had read and
understood the papers thank you chair
thank you thank you Emily that's very
help Mr chairman uh you had a question I
believe or something yes um a something
Mr chair I think can I just I think it's
wholly inappropriate to ask cabinet
members if they've read papers I agree
it's like it's like asking a turkey if
he's going to vote for Christmas of
course he's going to say no yeah I agree
I think we can move on that that's
that's that's a moot point now at this
point I'm uh directed by the protocol to
ask members of the cabinet and the lead
signatory to leave the meeting and I
believe that to imply the members of the
cabinet who uh presented arguments that
would be councilors Holt and Busby um I
don't believe it means the other members
of the cabinet um so I'm going to rule
in that way and the lead signatory to
leave the meeting again I'm not entirely
certain that this is strictly NE Neary
but nonetheless It's contained within
the protocol and and then we will go
into
debate thank you so thank you very much
all three of you for your efforts today
they are much
appreciated right at this point we'll
obviously find a way to let them know
after we've closed our debate and uh
decided upon any recommendations cancel
Owen are you're still
present okay okay so um Henrietta are we
ready to
go yes chair I'm just checking the list
and as far as I can see the um requested
members have left the meeting that's
fine right then so let's uh enter the
debate uh members are asked to debate
the issues we've got um the
presentations of the lead signatory the
cabinet members we've had the
opportunity to ask questions we've
received what I believe to be some very
useful information and guidance from the
monitoring officer since this is a
procedural matter that we are
considering was the procedure right and
we're asked to debate the issue and
there are three potential caes of action
uh in the uh consideration one is to
refer this back to the cabinet for
reconsideration together with any
observations cabinet would then take a
final decision and that decision would
not be able to be called in we can seek
the advice of the monitoring officer as
to whether the decision would be
contrary or not wholly in accordance
with the policy framework or the budget
and if if applicable refer the matter to
full Council for a final decision on
that point item two I believe that the
monitoring officer statement has fully
answered that question although you may
feel differently and three the other
option is to that the decision be upheld
and implemented immediately so over to
you members pleas please to open the
debate I have councelor
grandon thank you
chair um
I've been considering the three items
that the lead
signatory um put before us um as the
main matters to be
discussed and it seems to me that um
items one to three have been answered in
this morning's or this afternoon's
questions um it seems to me that the
consideration of options item number one
that the Lee signatur
discussed um were in the
papers read by the cabinet
members
and whether they were openly discussed
or not they
were um assessed by
them item two the presumption of
openness as far I understood it
correctly from yourself and the
monitoring
officer the matrix by law is not allowed
to be discussed in an open forum and a
very central part of that Matrix is the
figures and that would be contrary to
um to to what's allowed to be in the
open um Forum any
anyway and then item
three um the lack of clarity as to um
balancing the lot of open
space you appear to have Frozen
councelor
grandon you're addressing the open space
matter okay for the moment if councelor
Dawson is uh present perhaps we'll move
to councelor dwson and hope to come back
for councelor grandon to
complete okay mine just very quick to
say I I have to say that I think this
issue is so contentious I think it would
only be fair in light of all the
questions that it really came to full
Council for debate uh taking it away
from uh you know a few eight members of
the cabinet I think it would be more
appropriate to have a proper um all
members MERS can have a say on it
because at the end of the day in Sudbury
uh this is a huge contentious issue and
I think we must be seen to be
transparent so um my recommend I would
like it to go back to full Council I
think that's what I believe would be the
appropriate Way Forward shall we debate
further then uh councelor
gold yeah thank you um Sean you you've
really just said what very eloquently
what I was thinking
um and right on on the first point I
think it's interesting that it's worded
not all options listed in the report
were discussed and debated and it was
not clear why the alternative options
were not
chosen so that's that um point one
doesn't say it's not clear why they
weren't discussed it says it's not clear
why they weren't chosen um and to have
given a reason why five out of the six
weren't chosen
by definition must have meant that they
must have all had a brief discussion and
I think I I don't you know I don't fully
accept the um it was all there in the
paperwork I'm sure the cabinet read it
although I'm sure that I'm sure they did
but I don't necessarily accept that as
being a reason for not not actually
articulating it at cabinet meeting um so
I think we we you know I would like to
have to have heard that okay clearly one
had to be chosen um but but I think that
it it would have been trans arent and
much much more transparent and seemed to
be transparent if they'd all been
discussed and I agree with Sean I I
think it's exceedingly
sensitive um and I'm sure there were
members of the public listening in or
will be tuning in to here I see Emily U
has her hand raised Emily do you wish to
address these
points thank you chair I just wanted to
um provide some guidance on the uh issue
around referring it to council these are
executive function so cabinet is the
correct decision maker here therefore
the overview and scrutiny committee can
only refer the matter to the full
Council if it believes that the decision
was not consistent with policy or the
agreed budget um so just a a a
recommendation for referral for debate
is is not within your power for this
review chair yeah and I believe I mean
to address both the points there Council
and G have made in the fact that not
agreeing with the decision is not the
point here it's a question of whether
the procedural matters described in the
calling were in fact addressed one two
and three um and of course it's
important that the matters are discussed
if there are queries that's what a call
in is for councelor McLaren oh councelor
grandon are you back with
us yes I'm sorry um okay my line dropped
out you were at the point of discussing
open space face item three on the Callin
we returned to that oh oh I got that far
good yes you had we had you up till then
um
so oh we're not meant to hear it are we
and councelor G and McLaren could turn
your cameras off and maybe bandwidth and
I'll do the same can you hear me yeah we
can hear me we're just getting some
cameras turned off we can hear you thank
you you might be best to turn your
camera off as well
yes okay thank you um so I I was just
going to say that um for me item three
um were discussing balancing loss of
open space was probably the area that
was least answered but it seemed to me
that in our presentation today that that
can be not properly answered and so
while I agree with um the lead signatory
that um that balance of open space was
not properly um answered in the
meetings um it seems that that cannot be
done um so so while that there's a
question mark on it I think there always
would be so for me I would say that um
the three items of the call in the three
matters to consider have all been
answered um and Justified
today thank you very much
councelor there was fine I've got that
fine councelor uh let me I had councelor
McLaren up next and then councelor
Dawson and then counc Osborne thank you
chair um I've got to say that I felt in
terms of this process today I felt
satisfied with how um the process had
been undertaken by the cabinet however
I've I have to say that many of the
questions I had uh leave uh some doubt
in my mind whether but it has nothing to
do with this meeting but I did have more
questions about what had happened at the
cabinet meeting thank you okay thank you
I think we'll just have to stick with
the scope we have councelor Osborne and
councelor
Dawson councelor dwson you've spoken
already so I'll let councilor Osborne go
first if you don't mind yeah thank you
Mr chairman first of all um I tend to
agree with councilor grandon I think uh
that those particular um areas that were
were covered adequately by by the
officers and in particular our
monitoring officer Emily Yu um I can't I
cannot see any reason why
um you know there there are obviously
going to be question marks but I'm
afraid I you know I just don't think
that the the problems that are there
have they have been answered correctly
and and uh I you know I respect exactly
what they've said I I agree with them
thank
you thank you very much councelor
Osborne councelor
Dawson um yes the reason I'm sort of
bring because I believe that my
questions um that I want to ask can't
really haven't been answered in this
forum and so I think if there's a proper
debate about it um and for transparency
reasons I think they should come to full
Council well I'm not allow sorry I'm not
sorry carry on no no just by all means I
understand you you'd like you believe it
to come to cabinet that that's something
well no but it's because I don't feel
the questions I'm not being allowed to
ask questions here um today so I presume
that in full Council I can ask the
questions that's the issue I'm not able
to get back what it is we can only ask
questions within the scope of the
calling yes but that calling is is
defined not by us and not by the cabinet
but by the by those signatories yes but
again part of the part of the question
is in in in the process in the
evaluation four core strategies were
addressed and six weren't why were those
other two not would they possibly it's
they're not relevant I don't know
they're not they're not they're not
within our scope councelor Dawson if
it's a simple matter of procedure and
fact that we can't review something that
we haven't been asked to don't have the
power to sorry you're misunderstanding I
think in The Matrix
four of the strategies are in there and
not six so in fact we are addressing
that within the scope
clearly that's not the aspect of the
Matrix that was uh referred to in the
Callin that that is the Matrix itself so
I can't agree with you there councelor
Dawson I don't believe it is within the
scope and I'm making that ruling as
chair yes so therefore as we're um it's
quite clear these these things I think
you need to look at 6.1 and then refer
back to the Matrix yeah we can't do that
coun Emily you you have your hand
raised thank you chair I just wondered
if it was um pertinent to remind
councilors that all members of the
council have access to the uh cabinet
committee P cabinet papers um and indeed
to the overview and scrutiny committee
papers um and that all councilors can
ask questions of the cabinet um at its
meeting meetings um and indeed the
leader of the council normally allows
other councilors present at the cabinet
meetings to ask questions from the floor
during the discussions um so actually
there is opportunity for councilors to
raise these points before the decision
is made during that that cabinet
discussion thank you chair thank you
very much Emily um I noticed that Sue's
councelor has a hand raised I'm afraid
councelor as this is a debate for the
Comm
Alone um so we'll move on I'd just like
to make a few comments myself um and
perhaps we can begin to draw to a close
in quite a matter of of some yes there's
concern yes I would to come back on
Emily's comment sorry councelor Dawson
am I able to come back on Emily's
comment I believe so but please um well
I take on board Emily fully what you're
saying however however um you know the
cabinet don't listen to uh as my
experience and that's why I think it
should be openly discussed because it's
such a big issue councelor Dawson that's
not what we're here to discuss and no no
exactly but I mean the point is is there
isn't really a forum for us to discuss
this and that's why it should come to
full Council I think I think it's a
nature of Cabinet Government and I think
that's something that address we we
could address and a wider issue within
Council but don't think this is the
place so I giving my reasons why it
should come to full Council absolutely
but I'm afraid I'm afraid the reasons
aren't something we can discuss here and
today I think that would be appropriate
elsewhere uh at a different time um I
all I will say is that I attend I think
I've attended cabinet for the
consistently for the last three years I
don't think I've missed more than one
meeting and the opportunity does exist
for members to to be aware of cabinet
considerations and I I can say that um I
have sat through this subject and I
recall all the points raised um both
within the Callin and uh and within
General discussion actually being
discussed at length uh all the
objections that people still hold fine
it's quite reasonable not to agree with
the decision but it's okay don't worry
yeah I understand yeah I'm so sooner or
later a decision has to be made this is
this is basically my cont contribution
to the debate um so all I will say is
that I believe that one two and three
were addressed the consideration of
options was there it was present in the
report um we are not there to describe
what cabinet must or must not discuss
the presumption of openness it's not in
my view possible to publish or an open
session a partial Matrix one it would
serve no purpose and two it would be
easy to deduce uh content from whatever
information was supplied and three I
think the matter of open space I don't
think there was a lack of clarity any
more than exists within the very
definition of open space and I'm aware
of a piece of open space in my own Ward
which is a narrow strip of land for
Access nobody is proposing that people
will go frolicking there it's just a
simple definition so I'm quite satisfied
that all three of the call-in notices
points were addressed and I'm going to
propose that the council sorry the
cabinet the committee
rather I'm proposing that the decision
be upheld and implemented immediately I
can't see any other choice on the basis
of the information provided by the
monitoring officer the answers given to
questions were the cabinet entitled to
make the decision yes they were I draw
members attention incidentally to the
decision notice which makes it quite
plain that this process is not complete
that delegated authority is given to the
assistant director for economic growth
and
regeneration and that there are there
are still things to be determined that
may address some of the concerns raised
by people in Sudbury and wider field so
I'm making that proposal and I'd ask for
a seconder that the decision be upheld
and implemented
immediately
I'm seconding that chairman thank you
councelor
McLaren uh councelor Osborne did you
wish to
speak um no I would I was going to
second that with with with the your
excellent description of uh what was for
our our um approval and what wasn't so
thank you there's no question it's it's
important that these matters were raised
they have been fully discussed I believe
they were more maybe not quite so fully
discussed within cabinet but they were
done done if you were there it was a
lengthy meeting some two and a half
hours might have been spent on that
subject um difficult to remember
everything um any other member wish to
say anything to debate on this subject
or shall we go to a
vote in that case I'll ask the
governance officer Henry at Holloway to
open the uh electronic
vote
thank you chair um I have now I will now
open the uh vote for you if you just
bear with me one moment please if you go
to your agenda and scroll down towards
the end of the agenda you will see there
are three votes um I will activate one
of them for you which is the one that
was proposed by the chair and it'll be
highlighted by Blue
Line If members can cast their votes
please
Mr chairman can can you just um can you
just uh clarify the the voting position
on that please of what it was uh I I
must have missed it The Proposal is that
the decision be upheld and implemented
immediately and that should be the line
that is highlighted in
blue thank you very much thank
you chair I'm still waiting for one vote
from councelor
Osborne I have not received that vote
for Council Osborne chair so the votes
are five votes for and one
against thank you very much
henriet so that uh means we can now
actually we should have come out of this
session and let invited the cabinet
members back in before we took that vote
but if we can uh maybe make contact with
them and the uh
the uh the lead signatory to the call-in
uh my apology to those members for that
um perhaps we go back into Open Session
but I think uh that concludes the
meeting today um thank you very much for
your attention it was an exhaustive
process but I think we we did the right
thing went through all the details went
through each of the points raised under
the Callin and we were clear in why we
made our decision the next joint
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
will be as previously mentioned
um in May I believe the 24th at
9:30 and at that meeting I believe we'll
be uh carrying out an annual review of
the work of the overview and scrutiny
committee thank you members for very
much for your time thank officers for
your time and effort and uh I will see
you around some other time